THE.
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER AND
WE WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THE FIRST ITEM.
FIRST ITEM WILL BE.
FILE ITEM ONE.
OH OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON PLEASE
NOTE THAT FILE ITEM ONE A. B.
EIGHT NINETY SIX.
HAS BEEN PULLED.
WITH THE CONSENT OF THE AUTHOR.
ALSO NOTE THAT OUR GUIDANCE FOR
BILLS HEARD THIS AND COMMITTEE
TODAY IS TO ALLOW TESTIMONY.
FROM TWO WITNESSES FOR SUPPORT
AND TWO WITNESSES FOR
OPPOSITION.
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
I WILL ALSO CALLED FOR TWEETERS
TESTIMONY THOSE WHO ARE NEITHER
IN SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE TO A
MEASURE.
AND THEN THE.
CORRECT.
FILE ITEM ONE WAS PULLED OUT FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE FIRST BILL
MISS CUT BY YET.
WHICH IS FILE ITEM NINE.
WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR.
WHICH WOULD CREATE THE EMERGENCY
STUDENT HOUSING LOAN PROGRAM A
PILOT PROGRAM AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. TO HELP
HOMELESS STUDENTS OR STUDENTS AT
RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS TO
SECURE HOUSING SO THEY CAN STAY
IN SCHOOL. THE RISE IN THE COST
OF LIVING HAS AFFECTED ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND STUDENTS REALLY
ARE NO EXCEPTION.
A RECENT STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE
CSU FOUND APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN
PERCENT OF ITS STUDENTS HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS ONE OR
MORE TIMES IN THE PAST TWELVE
MONTHS.
FIRST GENERATION AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR FACE AN EVEN HIGHER RISK
OF HOUSING IN SECURITY. AND
EXPERIENCE HIGHER RATE OF
HOMELESSNESS
REPORTS OF STUDENTS SLEEPING IN
CROWDED AND TINY APARTMENTS CARS
SHELTERS AND STREETS ARE COMMON.
FOR MOST STUDENTS HOUSING IS
THEIR LARGEST EXPENSE WITH THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL CSU TUITION AND
FEES AMOUNTING TO OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THE AVERAGE
ANNUAL HOUSING COST OVER
THIRTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
AT.
ANNUALLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS IMPLEMENTED THE HOMELESS
PREVENTION AND RAPID RE HOUSING
PROGRAM TO TACKLE HOMELESSNESS.
RAPID RE HOUSING IS AN
INTERVENTION MODEL TO RAPIDLY
CONNECT FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO
PERMANENT HOUSING WALK WHILE
CONNECTING THEM TO OTHER
RESOURCES AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WOULD TAILOR RAPID RE
HOUSING TO THE CSU SYSTEM.
ALLOWS ALLOWING THREE
PARTICIPATING CAMPUSES TO
PROVIDE LOANS TO ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS.
STUDENTS WHO LOSE HOUSING ARE
MORE LIKELY TO OUR DROPPED OUT
OF COLLEGE LEADING TO HIGHER
RISK OF BECOMING CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS FOR CALIFORNIA TO MEET
ITS FUTURE SKILLED WORKFORCE
NEEDS NEEDS TO SUPPORT THE MOST
VULNERABLE MOBILE STUDENTS.
ADDRESSING STUDENT HOMELESSNESS
REQUIRES A MULTIFACETED APPROACH
AND AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT.
HOUSING COSTS.
IT WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OUR JARED JERUSALEM WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND DOCTOR KIZI
LOPEZ COORDINATOR OF THE
RENAISSANCE SCHOLARS PROGRAM AT
CSU FRESNO. MOVE THE BILL.
BUT WE.
BUT IT WAS.
GOOD TAKE.
TENANTS.
YEAH
NO SEVEN YEAH.
YEAH.
WE'LL GO AHEAD.
WE'RE GONNA GO.
WE'RE GONNA JUST STOP FOR A
MINUTE TO.
ESTABLISH SUPPORT.
MEDINA PRESS
BAKER. ARAMBULA. BLOOM CHAVEZ.
IRWIN.
KILEY LEVINE LOW PATTERSON QUIRK
SILVA.
SANTIAGO WEBER.
SEE.
OKAY ADVOCATE GOOD AFTERNOON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
MEMBERS GET MY NAME IS GERRY
JERVIS I REPRESENT BECAUSE IT'S
AN ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
NEARLY HALF A MILLION I'M CSU
STUDENTS STATEWIDE.
WERE REALLY THANKFUL FOR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE BY SOME REMEMBER CABALLERO
I'M FOR YEARS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
HEARD THE STORIES OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS. IN BOTH CASES IT WITH
AN INDIVIDUAL PROFILE HERE AND
THERE OF THE SUIT STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. AS TIME PASSED
WE'VE BECOME MORE MORE AWARE OF
HOW PRESSING ISSUE THIS. ISSUE
OF.
HOMELESSNESS IS IN CALIFORNIA
AND HOW THAT CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS HAS NOT.
OF.
ALLUDED SADDAM COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THANK THE RESEARCH CONDUCTED BY
CSU WE NOW KNOW SYSTEM MY
NUMBERS.
WITH RESPECT HOMELESSNESS
ELEVEN PERCENT IF YOU IF YOU
STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS THAT MEANS
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CSU
STUDENTS DO NOT KNOW WHERE
THEY'LL BE SLEEPING NIGHT
TONIGHT HAVING TO FIND SHELTER
SLEEPING IN THEIR CARS. OR
BACKING A FRIENDS ALLOW THEM TO
STAY WITH THEM FOR ANOTHER NIGHT
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY TRYING TO
SUCCEED IN COLLEGE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS PERCENTAGE AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED IS.
MUCH HIGHER FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS IN FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS THAT I
EIGHTEEN PERCENT OF HOMELESSNESS
RATES.
THIS IS WHY HAVING A TARGET AND
PREVENT PROGRAM LIKE THE ONE
OUTLINED IN AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR IS SO CRITICAL TO
SOLVING THIS ISSUE. AND PILOTING
A PROGRAM LIKE THIS I'M IN THE
CSU MAKES PERFECT SENSE.
IF YOU IF YOU ADMINISTRATION IN
THE INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORTING HOMELESS STUDENTS
WITH EXTREMELY LIMITED RESOURCES
WHETHER IT'S I'M STOPPING A
SYSTEM WIDE OPPOSITION TO THE
ANALYZE BASIC NEEDS. OR
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES OFFERING
EMERGENCY LOANS.
EMERGENCY GRANTS I'M IN EVEN
FINDING EMERGENCY HOUSING I'M
HAVING.
A SOLUTION LIKE THE ONE
PRESENTED IN AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR WOULD JUST BE AN
ADDITIONAL TOOLS IN THE TOOL KIT
FOR A FOR CAMPUS IS LOOKING TO
SUPPORT HOMELESS STUDENTS.
WE BELIEVE CAL STATE SINCE.
IS CELTICS IN ASSOCIATION
BELIEVES THAT IF WE CAN SOLVE
THE CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS IN
THE CSU WE CAN GO A LONG WAY TO
HELPING SOLVE CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS THE STATE.
A COLLEGE EDUCATION AGREE YOU
FROM THE CSU IN PARTICULAR HAS A
PROVEN POSITIVE IMPACT ON AN
INDIVIDUAL'S ABILITY TO HAVE
UPWARD SOCIAL MOBILITY. COUPLE
THAT WITH THE FACT THAT OVER
HALF OF THIS UC'S POPULATION IS
PALATABLE COMING FROM EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME BACKGROUNDS THERE MAY
BE NO GREATER LONG TERM WAY TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS STATEWIDE
AND SUPPORTING OUR HOME WITH
COLLEGE STUDENTS TODAY.
THIS ISSUE IS HEARTBREAKING THE
WITNESS STUDENTS ARE MERELY
TRYING TO COMPLETE THEIR DEGREES
SO THEY CAN BETTER THEMSELVES
THEIR COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
AND WE HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
CHOOSE TO SUPPORT OUR NEEDIEST
STUDENTS AND AND VOTE TO PASS A
BETWEEN SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT TO THINK
THAT COULD MAYBE AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS COPPING ARROW IN AROUND
THE LEFT FOR. CARRYING THIS BILL
IT SO IMPORTANT MY NAME IS
DOCTOR KIZI LOPEZ AND I SERVE AS
THE COORDINATOR OF THE
RENAISSANCE SCHOLARS PROGRAM AT
FRESNO STATE. RENAISSANCE CALLER
SERVES STUDENTS.
WHO'VE EXPERIENCED FOSTER CARE
OR UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH.
I KNOW FIRST HAND WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO BE HOMELESS WHILE IN
COLLEGE.
AND WHEN I STARTED COLLEGE I WAS
HOMELESS FOR THE FIRST THREE
MONTHS OF WITHOUT PARENTAL
SUPPORT. I REMEMBER TRYING TO
MAINTAIN MY BASIC HYGIENE ACROSS
THE STREET AT TACO BELL.
THAT RESTAURANT THAT WAS ACROSS
THE STREET AT THE SCHOOL.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE I STRUGGLED
ACADEMICALLY I'M A DOCTOR TODAY
BUT YOU KNOW MY GRADES WOULD
HAVE TOLD YOU THAT BACK THEN.
I CANNOT FOCUS ON SCHOOL I'LL
ALL I THOUGHT ABOUT WAS WHERE I
WAS GOING TO SEE HOW IT'S GOING
TO GET MY NEXT MEAL. AND IT
HONESTLY WAS A VERY DARK TIME IN
MY LIFE AND I HAD TO MAKE SOME
REALLY TOUGH ETHICAL DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW I WOULD SURVIVE.
I I KNOW THAT THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE OUT FOR MY COLLEGE
WOULD HAVE MADE A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE AND HELPING NEED MY
BASIC MEANS.
THAT WOULD ALLOW ME TO FOCUS IN
SCHOOL BUT INSTEAD I STRUGGLED A
MY CONFIDENCE WAS SHAKEN AND.
IT TOOK ME ALMOST TEN YEARS TO
GET A BACHELORS DEGREE OFTEN ON.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COPIER TALKED
ABOUT THE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
OF PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS IN COLLEGE A
STUDENTS OF COLOR. ALSO A
STUDENTS WHO'VE BEEN A
PROSECUTOR EXTREMELY VULNERABLE
AND SO SOMEONE LIKE ME AS A
WOMAN OF COLOR LOW INCOME AND
HAVE EXPERIENCE FOSTER CARE I
WAS THAT VULNERABLE STUDENT.
AND.
MY STORY I'M VERY FORTUNATE AND
VERY LUCKY BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE I
SHOULDN'T BE THE EXCEPTION.
I HAVE DEDICATED MY PROFESSIONAL
LIFE TO IMPROVING THE
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES OF FOSTER
YOUTH AND HOMELESS YOU THINK
COLLEGE BECAUSE OF MY OWN
EXPERIENCES. I DO NOT WANT TO
SEE STUDENTS MAKE THOSE
DIFFICULT ETHICAL CHOICES I HAD
TO MAKE JUST TO SURVIVE INSTEAD
I WANT MY STUDENTS TO FOCUS ON
SCHOOL AND BUILDING THEIR
FEATURES.
RENAISSANCE SCHOLARS IS ABLE TO
SERVE SIXTY STUDENTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
BUT WE'VE HEARD STATEWIDE
THERE'S ELEVEN PERCENT OF
STUDENTS IN THIS ISSUE ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
I'M A LITTLE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
CAN BE TRANSFORMATIVE IN THE
LIVES OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE I
REMEMBER IT WAS THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. BEST THAT.
.
I NEED IT AND I COULDN'T GET AND
I WAS HOMELESS.
THEREFORE.
I WANT TO STATE THAT AS A A
FORMER HOMELESS STUDENT AND NOW
PRACTITIONER SUPPORTING THIS
POPULATION. I SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT OF THIS BILL AND I AM
WANT TO PARTNER WITH YOU ALL
INVESTING IN THESE VERY
TALENTED.
STUDENTS IN THE CSU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON TURNED MEMBERS A
DROUGHT OF WELL THAT'S WHAT THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE HERE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. OF RAPID RE
HOUSING IS A SUCCESSFUL
INNOVATION AND SOCIAL POLICY
THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX GRAVES AT
THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OUR
POSITIONS CURRENTLY PENDING BUT
WE HOPE TO GET TO A SUPPORT
POSITION IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. OUT WE'RE
VERY. CONCERNED ABOUT THIS ISSUE
AND WORKING ACTIVELY ON OUR
CAMPUSES ACROSS OUR SYSTEM TO
ADDRESSES OF THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF THE TWENTY
THOUSAND FACULTY COUNSELORS
LIBRARIANS AND COACHES OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THINK.
ANGELIQUE YORK WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRISTOPHER MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND I I SAID I WOULD.
ASTRID TWEENER SO ANY ANY
BETWEEN HERS ON THIS BILL.
NONE.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE
WANTING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE. COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR RUMBLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANTED
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO COME TO PRESENT
STATE AND TO SPEAK TO OUR
STUDENTS.
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR THOSE OF US
WHO OFTENTIMES FEEL LIKE WE'RE
NOT A. HAPPY SEAT AT THE TABLE
TO BE HEARD AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS MEASURE THAT'S BEFORE US
WILL HELP TO ADDRESS A CRITICAL
PROBLEM THAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN
TOO MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
BUT I ALSO WANTED TO FIGHT
COULD TAKE A SECOND TO THANK
DOCTOR LOPEZ.
IT'S A.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAD THIS.
PRESS CONFERENCE TO HELP
UNVEILED THIS BILL WE ACTUALLY
STRUGGLE TO GET A STUDENT TO
TELL THEIR STORY. AND DOCTOR
LOPEZ STEPPED UP AND WAS ABLE
TO.
IT HIGHLIGHTS HOW.
HARD IT IS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY.
TO HAVE A VOICE RIGHT NOW AND I
JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TO SHARE THAT.
LOOKING FORWARD TO SUPPORTERS.
BECAUSE BAKER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR M. ALSO THINK THE MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FOR A. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S THREE
CAMPUSES AND THAT WON'T WILL BE.
DETERMINED BY THE BOARD AND NOT
BY THIS BODY AND I.
.
GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
I'D BE VERY INTERESTED IN SEEING
IF THERE WOULD BE ANY GUIDANCE
AND HOPEFULLY CONSIDERATION BY
THEM A LOOK IN THOSE AREAS WHERE
THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING IS
PARTICULARLY SEVERELY HI YOU
KNOW I DON'T HAVE A. C. ISSUE IN
MY DISTRICT BUT.
THERE'S ONE IN SAN JOSE WHICH
IS RIGHT IN THE HEART OF SILICON
VALLEY. STUDENTS AND FAMILIES GO
THERE AND.
YOU KNOW HOUSING IS OBVIOUSLY AN
ISSUE IN THE BAY AREA. AS WELL
AS THAT CAL STATE EAST BAY. AND
AND HEAVY CONSIDERATION FOR
WHERE THERE'S THREE CAMPUSES ARE
AT LEAST ONE OF THEM.
BEING IN AN AREA THAT IS.
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY
EXORBITANTLY HIGH HOUSING AND
I'M SURE SOMEBODY COULD POINT
OUT THAT THERE'S LOTS OF PLACES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE THAT
ISSUE.
BUT I THINK IT'S IT'S SEVERE FOR
STUDENTS WHEN THEY'RE LIVING IN
ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE. AREAS
IN THE COUNTRY.
AT HOPE THAT CAN BE A
CONSIDERATION OR GUIDANCE GIVEN
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WE CAN DO
THAT RIGHT I DON'T THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE IN THE BILL BUT I.
WANNA GET THAT OUT THERE THAT
SUPPORT FOR THAT TO BE. PART OF
THE CONVERSATION.
.
AND I'D LIKE THAT THIS IS A
PILOT WE NEED TO SEE IF THIS IS
GOING TO WORK AT THIS IS THE
BEST WAY TO PUT THESE DOLLARS
THERE'S LOTS OF WAYS TO HELP
STUDENTS WHO ARE FACING HOUSING
CRISIS AND IF THIS IS THE BEST
ONE TO DO IT. AND I APPRECIATE
THEM.
THE PILOT IS FAIRLY NARROW IN
TIME BECAUSE A SUNSET IS JUST A
FEW YEARS HUESO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT AND I'M JUST KID SEEN
ON WHERE THEY PICK THOSE THREE
CAMPUSES.
NOT SEEN ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
GOVERNOR.
PHAM APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS I'M
AT WE'VE SPECIFICALLY LEFT IT
OPEN IN TERMS OF THE THREE
CAMPUSES MY GUESS IS IT'S GOING
TO BE DIFFICULT. TO DECIDE
BECAUSE THEIR CAMPUSES ARE ALL
VERY DIFFERENT AND HAVE
DIFFERENT RESOURCES LOCATED
WITHIN A.
THE DISTANCE ON THAT FACT THAT
SOME ARE BRAND NEW AND HAVE VERY
LITTLE HOUSING IN SUMMER REALLY.
MUCH OLDER BUT HAVE GROWN.
THAT.
CITIES HAVE GROWN UP AROUND THE
MAKE IT.
AT IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE BUT I UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT I
THINK.
MOST OF CALIFORNIA.
IS IN A CRITICAL STE
STAGE OF HOUSING AFFORD OR LACK
OF AFFORDABILITY AND SO. I DON'T
THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
EASY CHOICE BUT WE NEED SOME
REALLY GOOD MODELS TO TELL US
WHETHER THIS WORKS AND WHETHER
THERE ARE SOME THINGS WE OUGHT
TO BE DOING DIFFERENTLY. THAT
WILL HELP STUDENTS FIND HOUSING
AROUND THE CAMPUSES.
I ALSO WANNA.
I THINK DR POT LOPEZ FOR COMING
AND FOR SHARING HER STORY AND I
THINK PART OF THE CHALLENGE THAT
WE FOUND. IN FRESNO IS THAT
STUDENTS ARE SO EMBARRASSED TO
BE HOMELESS THAT THEY JUST DON'T
WANT TO COME FORWARD AND SO I
KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
ADMIT. TO HAVE BEEN IN TO HAVE
BEEN IN THAT SITUATION AND I
APPRECIATE HER.
DOCTOR LOW PRICES ON.
IT EXPERIENCE AND HER
WILLINGNESS TO SHARE IT WITH US
IT THAT THAT MAKES IT SOUND SO
POWERFUL.
AND ALSO I THINK MR MR EACH
YEAR IS THOUGH FOR FOR COMING
ALL THIS WAY AS WELL THIS IS A
CRITICAL. IN IN MY REGION IT CSU
AND BE ITS MARI BAY.
AT CSU AND I'M EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE AND PEOPLE ARE THAT
STUDENTS ARE LIVING IN THEIR
CARS AND I I CANNOT IMAGINE WHAT
IT'S LIKE.
TO TRY TO GO TO COLLEGE WHICH
WAS DIFFICULT ENOUGH.
AN NBA HOMELESS AND SO THE MORE
THAT WE CAN CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS TO. BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED A MILLION.
DEGREES OF AT STUDENTS WITH THE
GREASE.
WITHIN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME AND THESE ARE THE STUDENTS
THAT HAVE COMMITTED THEMSELVES
TO GET THERE AND SO WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THEM SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU A MISCARRIAGE.
I'VE CERTAINLY HEARD FROM THE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
IT FOR MY REPORTS IN THE MEDIA
HOW ABOUT WHAT AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE THIS IS OF HOMELESSNESS.
AMONG STUDENTS SO I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THE THE BILL
FORWARD AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING HOW THE MODEL WORKS.
TO ASSIST
THE STUDENT POPULATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY.
DR ARAMBULA AND A SECOND BY
DOCTOR WEBER. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MADAM SECRETARY
CULTURAL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM.
CHAVEZ
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I.
LOW.
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
UIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
YOU VERY MUCH.
EIGHT ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE.
MISTER BONTA.
WHO HAS TWO BILLS? NOT HERE OKAY
WILL GO NEXT TO MR WANT THIS
THAT.
WELCOME MR MONTHS.
AND THAT'S I A ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX.
ITEM ONE
.
MAYBE GET. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES A LEGAL PRIVILEGE OF
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN A SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT. AND A SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELOR AB EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX
WOULD CLARIFY THAT THIS LEGAL
PRIVILEGE APPLIES TO SEXUAL SAW
COUNSELORS PROVIDING SERVICES
AND SUPPORT. TO STUDENTS
SURVIVORS AT A PUBLIC COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY WITH INCREASED
ATTENTION TO THE ALARMING ISSUE
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT OCCURRING AT
OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES THERE'S A
NEED FOR INCREASED NUMBER OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS. TO
PROVIDE A SAFE SPACE AN
APPROPRIATE ASSISTANCE FOR
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL IS DUE ALSO RAMIREZ
WITH THE CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WHOSE A SPONSOR OF
THE BILL. AS WELL AS MY OUR
BROMO VICTIM ADVOCATE AND
PREVENTION EDUCATOR I CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ HILLS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME
TODAY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SURVIVE THIS FOR INTRODUCING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
MY NAME IS MEYER RAMON I INTO
SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIM ADVOCATE A
PREVENTION EDUCATOR I CALIFORNIA
STATE DOMINGUEZ HILLS.
I HAVE BEEN A SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELOR FOR ELEVEN YEARS
INCLUDING SEVEN YEARS IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND HAVE PROVIDED
DIRECT SUPPORT TO OVER THREE
HUNDRED SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT IT EIGHTEEN
F. A. B. EIGHTEEN AB SEX.
AS A SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELOR IT
IS MY RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE
A SAFE SPACE AND SUPPORT
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SEXUAL SAW IS A VERY TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE THE LONG TERM
EFFECTS.
MY JOB IS TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT
PULSE ASSAULT.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT HAVING A
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELOR
MINIMIZES THE RISK FOR
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
AND FACILITIES REPORTING MEDICAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL CARE.
IN MANY INSTANCES SEXUAL SUCK
CANCERS OTHER FIRST RESOURCE THE
SURVIVORS ENCOUNTER.
WE DO OUR BEACH WE INFORM
STUDENTS THAT WE ARE A
CONFIDENTIAL RESOURCE.
IF A STUDENT DECIDES TO FOLLOW
THE POLICE REPORT OR TITLE NAY
REPORT WE ARE THEREDURING THE
ENTIRE PROCESS TO PRICE SUPPORT.
ONE ASPECT OF OUR WORK OFTEN
MISUNDERSTOOD IS OUR SCOPE.
WE ACTUALLY PROVIDE A COMPANY
WITH AND SUPPORT OUTSIDE CAMPUS
INCLUDING ACCOMPANIMENTS TO
START EXAMS WHICH ARE ALSO KNOWN
ASK YOU TO RAPE KITS OR MEDICAL
FRIENDS EXAMS.
WE ALSO CREDIT COMPANY MINSKOFF
CAMPUS TO THE COURT SYSTEMS AND
OFF CAMPUS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
WE PROVIDE A SIMILAR RANGE OF
SERVICES AS OUR COMMUNITY BASED
RAPE CRISIS CENTERS BUT TAYLOR
TOOK COLLEGE STUDENT POPULATION.
SINCE WE ARE PART OF THE CAMPUS
CULTURE COMMUNITY WE ARE
ASSESSABLE AND MANY SURVIVORS
TRUST US AND FEEL SAFE SEEKING
SUPPORT WITH THE CAPUS BASED
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELOR.
CAMPUS BI SEXUAL SO CANCERS ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE PROTECTIONS
UNDER STATE LAW TO ENGAGE IN
PRIVILEGED COMMUNICATIONS AND
QUALIFY UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
EVIDENCE CODE SECTION TEN THIRTY
FIVE POINT TWO.
HOWEVER THERE IS INCONSISTENT
CHARACTERIZATION OF WHO
QUALIFIES THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELOR.
SO PRACTICING SEXUAL*
COUNSELORS AND OTHER AGENCIES
THAT SUPPORT SURVIVORS BELIEVE
THE CAMPUS BASED SEXUAL ASSAULT
CANCERS ARE NOT QUALIFIED. UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA EVIDENCE CODE AND
CANNOT PROVIDE FOR PRIVILEGED
COMMUNICATIONS.
THIS ASSERTING AMONGST SEXUAL
SUCK COUNSELORS INTERFERES WITH
OUR ABILITY TO FULLY SUPPORT
SURVIVORS.
JUST IMAGINE THAT A SURVIVOR WAS
BRAIN ENOUGH BRAVE ENOUGH TO
TRUST JUST CAMPUS SEXUAL SUCK
COUNSELOR. BUT THEN IT'S
INFORMED BY SOMEONE ELSE A
DIFFERENT AGENCY THAT IN FACT.
WE ARE ACTUALLY NOT PRIVILEGED
AND CONFIDENTIAL AS WE HAVE
STATED TO THEM.
WHAT AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX WILL
DO IS CLARIFIED SINCE STRINGENCY
AND VALIDATE THE CAMPUS BASED
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS
ARTIFACT PRIVILEGE?
UNDER THE EVIDENCE CODE THIS
WILL ALLOW US TO ADVOCATE FOR
OFF CAMPUS RESOURCES MORE
EFFECTIVELY.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
SURVIVORS FEEL SAFE TO ACCESS
THE CAMPUS SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELOR. AND THAT THEY RECEIVE
A CONSISTENT MESSAGE THAT THEIR
CONVERSATIONS AND SERVICES ARE
CONFIDENTIAL AND PROTECTED.
I THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU REGARDING EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY SIX.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX MY NAME IS
SO SEVEN YES AND I'M A STUDENT
ACT ATTENDING CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ HILLS AND
I'M ALSO THE SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
EQUITY SPEAKER. AND CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR CA
SHARE REPRESENTS A RIVER HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THE
CSU SYSTEM AND IS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF THAT SPELL I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAVANT THIS REINTRODUCING
THAT'S.
AND PROTECTING STUDENTS.
I'M.
THE UNCERTAINTY IN THE LAW HAD
DEPRIVE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT OF BEING FULLY SUPPORTED
AND DIRECTED. TO THE APPROPRIATE
FOR ALL SUCH AS COUNSELING
CENTER THAT'S NEEDED BALK AT THE
CENTER STUDENT WELLNESS AND
CAMPUS ARE COMMUNING LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND ESPECIALLY CAMPUS WITH A
SEXUAL THOUGHT COUNSELOR AND
ALSO INTERFERE WITH THE RIGHT TO
BE ACCOMPANIED TO MEETINGS.
BETWEEN THE VICTIM AND POLICE
PROSECUTORS ARE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS DUE TO THE FEAR
THAT COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE
CAMPUS SEXUAL THOUGHT COUNSELOR
VICTIM ARE NOT PRIVILEGED.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS VICTIMS
ENCOUNTER PRESSURE THE VICTIM TO
MAKE IMPORTANT LIFE I'M CHANGING
DECISIONS AT THE MOMENT.
QUESTIONS THAT MAY FURTHER
DISEMPOWERED VICTIMS AND ALLOW
THEM TO BLAME THEMSELVES FOR THE
ASSAULT ONE INVADING A VICTIM'S
PRIVACY.
BUT SUCH A BONE OF A MOMENT IT
IS IMPORTANT SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS TO FEEL SUPPORTED AND
BE GRANTED. THE OPERA BREA AND.
CORRECT INFORMATION THROUGHOUT
THEIR ENTIRE HEALING PROCESS.
WHICH IS OFTEN UNCLEAR AND
DIFFICULT BY CLARIFYING THE
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE COMMITTEE
AUDI AND PROTECTION OF THE
SURVIVORS TO CAMPUS WITH COUNSEL
A PRIVILEGE.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT STUDENTS
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT THAT
SEEK HELP OR INTERVENTION FROM
THEIR COLLEGE UNIVERSITY
SHELLING COUNTER HE SYSTEM THAT
PROVIDES TOM INFORMED
COORDINATED CONFIDENTIAL
SUPPORT.
THAT ADDRESSES THEIR NEEDS BEING
A VICTIM OF SEXUAL ASSAULT CAN
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE STUDENTS
MENTAL PHYSICAL HEALTH OVER A
WELLNESS AND ACADEMIC OUTCOMES.
SUCH A FAILURE AND DEPRESSION OR
ANXIETY.
I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION AND STUDENTS ABILITY
YOU HAVE CONTROL OVER HOW THEY
WISH TO RESPOND EMPOWERING
SURVIVOR IS ENSURING THAT WE
CLOSE THE GAPS THAT PREVENT OUR
STUDENTS FROM FEELING SAFE.
STUDENT SURVIVORS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DISTURB POSITIVE
SCHOOL CLIMATE AND SUPPORT
SYSTEMS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YOU THAT
AND YOU MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF OF
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WE DON'T
HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION TODAY.
YET HOWEVER WE DO APPRECIATE
THE MEMBER PICKING THIS FORWARD
WHERE STAND LIKE YOUR FIRST
WITNESS HERE THAT THAN WE DO
BELIEVE WE HAVE A CURRENT
AUTHORITY UNDER THE OF HIS COAT.
WE DO APPRECIATE CLARIFICATION
THEY BY THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MERRY GO ON WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HOW THE MAQUIS Y. ON BEHALF OF
CSU STUDENTS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH?
MIA QUE JANICE ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO STATE STUDENTS I
SUPPORT.
ANY BETWEEN HERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE TO SURVIVE THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS MATTER IN THAT WE STAND
WITH THEIR STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
SO I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. AND.
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY WE NEED A MOTION.
THANK YOU.
SO MOVED BY DOCTOR WEBER A
SECOND BY MISTER LOW.
A MADAM SECRETARY GOOD CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION S TO PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER
ARAMBULA. BLOOM.
CHAVEZ.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT.
THANK YOU.
THE WHOLE.
THROWS HER.
OKAY WE'LL GO NEXT TO MR HOLD.
HAS TWO BILLS.
TO PRESENT.
ITEM EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN WITHOUT.
OR.
ALRIGHT SO WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
PERCENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN. THE BILL TO
ENHANCE PROTECTIONS.
A COLLEGE STUDENT ATHLETES.
I INTRODUCED TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN BECAUSE OF THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL WOUNDS OF
AMATEURISM WE VIEW COLLEGE
ATHLETICS THROUGH HAS OBSCURED
OUR VISION A REALITY.
OUR OLD SURE IDEALIZED CONCEPT
OF AMATEURISM AND COLLEGE SPORTS
IS MYTH THAT ENABLES THE STATUS
QUO. AND CONSEQUENTLY THE ENSUE
TO A TO IMPLEMENT POLICIES THAT
HARM COLLEGE ATHLETES
PHYSICALLY.
EMOTIONALLY AND FINANCIALLY.
WELL IMPROVEMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN OF THE GOODNESS OF
THE NC TWO WAYS HARD.
IT HAPPENED BECAUSE ATHLETES AT
ADVOCATES FOUGHT FOR FAIRNESS IN
QUESTION A SYSTEM. THAT IS
EXPLOITED TO.
RECENT NEWS SHOWS US MORE
PROGRESS NEEDS TO BE MADE.
THE STUDENT GENOCIDE MICHIGAN
STATE ENDURED ABUSE
ABUSES WHILE THE ADMINISTRATION.
COACHING STAFF
AND TITLE NINE OFFICE BILL TO
ADDRESS IT.
INSITU A THREW UP ITS HANDS
SAYING THAT DID NOT HAVE THE
JURISDICTION.
WHILE THIS WAS A FAR REACHING
TRAGEDY SADLY THESE TYPES OF
ABUSES OF COLLEGE ATHLETES ARE
NOT UNIQUE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN
SEEKS TO ADDRESS
PROBLEM IN A NEW WAY BY
REQUIRING EVERY COACH EMPLOYEE
OF THE ATHLETIC PROGRAM. AND
REPRESENTS AT THE IN SITU A TO
BE MANDATED REPORTERS FOR ABUSE
EVEN IF THE STUDENT. IS OVER THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN.
THIS BILL ALSO SEEKS TO ADDRESS
ECONOMIC PROBLEMS ATHLETES FACE
BY ALLOWING INSTITUTIONS TO
CREATE A TRUST FUND.
OR COLLEGE ATHLETES.
WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO RETAIN ANY
FUNDS THEY EARN UNTIL AFTER THEY
GRADUATE.
THE DEGREE COMPLETION FUN IS A
MECHANISM SCHOOLS CONFUSED TO
CREATE. AND CHOOSE HOW IT WILL
BE USED.
OPTIONS FOR POTENTIAL FUNDING
INCLUDE FINANCIAL AWARDS GIVEN
FOR ATHLETIC ACHIEVEMENT.
THE OLYMPIC AWARDS.
REVENUE THE SCHOOL MAKES FROM
METEORITES AND ENDORSEMENTS OR
STIPENDS IF THE IN SITU A OR
COURTS ALLOW THEM TO BE AWARDED
TO ATHLETES.
AN EXAMPLE OF THE LAST OPTION IS
THE IT O'BANION VERSES INSITU A
CASE.
A US DISTRICT COURT RULED IN
FAVOR OF O'BANNON AND REQUIRED
SCHOOLS TO AWARD FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THE ATHLETES PER YEAR WHILE
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL FOR THE USE OF
THEIR NAMES IMAGES.
AND LIKE WITH LIKELY LIKELINESS.
THIS RULING WAS LATER CHANGED BY
THE NINTH CIRCUIT WHO ALSO RULED
IN FAVOR OF A BAD AND BUT SAID
SCHOOLS CAN ONLY OFFER STUDENTS
FUNDING UP TO THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
IF A FUTURE COURT DETERMINED
STIPENDS ARE APPROPRIATE THIS
BILL CREATES A TRANSPARENT
RESPONSIBLE ONE FLEXIBLE
MECHANISM SCHOOLS CAN USE TO
ALLOW STUDENTS TO BENEFIT. FROM
THOSE FUNDS.
THIS BILL IS PERSONAL FOR ME.
BEFORE I STARTED MY JOURNEY IN
PUBLIC SERVICE I PLAYED COLLEGE
BASKETBALL FOR SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
WHILE THE IN SITU A WAS OUT THE
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
ORGANIZATION IT IS TODAY.
I HAVE FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE AND
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE A
COLLEGE ATHLETE.
THIS COLLEGE ATHLETES ARE
PUTTING EVERYTHING ON THE LINE
AND RISKING THEIR BODIES AND
FIRST PSALM ONE INJURY AWAY FROM
LOSING EVERYTHING.
OTHERS ARE AT RISK OF LOSING IT
ALL FOR SPEAKING OUT FOR THEIR
TEAM OR ANY ABUSES THERE
EXPERIENCING US COLLEGE COACHES
HAVE THE POWER TO KEEP YOU ON.
OR OFF THE TEAM.
THE NC TO A MAKES BILLIONS IN
REVENUE WHILE ATHLETES ARE
GIVING THEIR ALL TO THEIR SPORT.
AND THEIR EDUCATION WITHOUT THE
SAME RIGHTS AS OTHER STUDENTS ON
CAMPUS.
WHILE RECOGNIZING THAT MUCH
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
I'M ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND NARROWING MY BILL
TO ADDRESS THE TWO AREAS.
DESCRIBED ABOVE.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WILL
STRIKE
SECTIONS ONE AND TWO AND AND
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'LL INDULGE
ME. I WANTED TO READ THE
AMENDMENTS INTO THE RECORD
BECAUSE I KNOW BECAUSE OF THE
LATENESS OF HOW THE AMENDMENTS
WERE BEING PRESENTED.
THAT THEY MAY NOT BE BEFORE YOU
SO IF WITH YOUR PERMISSION.
WITH PERCY.
US SO THE BILL WHAT SPECIFICALLY
STRIKE SECTIONS ONE AND TWO.
AMEND SECTIONS THREE TO SAY AN
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER LEARNING
MAY ESTABLISH A DEGREE
COMPLETION FUN.
STRIKE SECTIONS FOUR AND FIVE.
AND KEEP SECTION SIX WHICH AMEND
SECTION ELEVEN ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE
POINT SEVEN OF THE PENAL CODE.
TO EXPAND THE MANDATED REPORTER
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THIS SECTION
TO COLLEGE STUDENTS OVER THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN.
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL WILL LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU.
AT TO REFINE THE LANGUAGE AND
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
SEGMENT.
I WITH ME TODAY AS WITNESSES A
REMOTE OUT REMOTELY HUMA.
NATIONAL COLLEGE.
A PLAYER'S ASSOCIATION EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND ANDY SCHWARTZ AND
ECONOMISTS AND PARTNER. AD O. SK
ARE AN ECONOMIC CONSULTING FIRM.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I.
THINK YOU THOUGHT BEFORE YOU
BEGIN I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
WHAT I SAID AT THE BEGINNING.
THAT I THE POLICY IN THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES.
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR TO
THAT.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY MANDY
SCHWARTZ I'M AN ECONOMIST WITH
THE WHAT'S CARE AREN'T
EMERYVILLE. I'VE BEEN STUDYING
COLLEGE SPORTS ECONOMIC SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. I'VE
ENCOUNTERED A LAUNDRY LIST OF
MYTHS Y. IT SOMETHING LIKE A
DEGREE COMPLETION FUND CANNOT
WORK.
THE FIRST MYTH YOU'LL HEAR IS
THAT COMPETITIVE BALANCE WILL BE
HARMED IN THAT'S FALSE.
THE BROAD CONSENSUS OF SPORTS
ECONOMISTS IS THAT. THE NCA CAPS
ON INDIVIDUAL ATHLETE EARNINGS.
BENEFITS DO NOT ENHANCE
COMPETITION VIRTUALLY ALL STAR
ATHLETES OVER NINETY NINE
PERCENT SIGNED WITH SCHOOLS AND
POWER CONFERENCES.
ALABAMA KENTUCKY DOMINATE THEIR
SPORTS BECAUSE OF THE CAPS NOT
DESPITE THEM.
SECOND MYTH THAT TITLE NINE
DOESN'T ALLOW SUCH FUNDING IS
FALSE.
WOMEN'S SPORTS SHARE IN A
IMPROVE BENEFITS RECENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CLARIFIED THAT OF MALE ATHLETES
RECEIVE COMPENSATION ABOVE COST
OF ATTENDANCE. THAT TITLE NINE
REQUIRES A PROPORTIONAL MATCH
FOR FEMALE ATHLETES.
AND SO IT'S CAPS ARE LIFTED MALE
AND FEMALE ATHLETES RISE
TOGETHER.
WHICH IS WHY SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN A SCHOOLS HAVE ADOPTED
CO WAY FOR MEN THEY'VE DONE SO
IN PROPORTION FOR WOMEN.
THIRD MYTH THAT IT WOULD DESTROY
NON REVENUE SPORTS IS ALSO
FALSE.
THERE ARE SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE DIVISION TWO AND THREE
SPORTS PROGRAMS WITH OVER TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND. ATHLETES
AND NONE OF THEM HAVE PROFITS
FROM FOOTBALLER BASKETBALL BUT
THEY MANAGED TO SPONSOR SPORTS.
FOR EXAMPLE YOU WITHOUT BIG
FOOTBALL AND BASKETBALL THEY'RE
ABOUT AS MANY DIVISION TO ACROSS
PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTRY. AS
DIVISION ONE.
FOURTH MYTH
SMALL SCHOOLS WON'T BE ABLE TO
COMPETE. ALSO FALSE
ANY SCHOOL THAT FEELS THAT THE
FUNDS IN QUESTION ARE GOOD
OPPORTUNITY ARE FREE NOT TO MAKE
THEM. THOSE WILL BE THE SAME
SCHOOLS THAT AREN'T PAYING THEIR
COACHES MILLION DOLLARS.
MINISTRY DOES HAPPEN MILLION
DOLLARS THERE ARE THREE EARNED
FIFTY ONE DIVISION ONE SCHOOLS
WHEN CO A WHAT'S ALLOWED ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY ADOPTED AT
THE REST DIDN'T BUT. STILL ONE
MARCH MADNESS ROLLED AROUND WE
GOT TO SEE SCHOOLS COMPETING
FROM BOTH LEVELS WITH GREAT
UPSETS.
THE MARKET HAS ALREADY SORTED
OUT THE PECKING ORDER AND THIS
BILL IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE WAY
THAT WE CAN HARNESS THOSE MARKET
FORCES. TO REACH OUT IMPROVE
SOCIAL OUTCOME FINALLY IN
CLOSING I JUST WANT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
THAT WAS A HEARING AT THE STATE
SENATE. SAYING THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE WOULD CAUSE ALL OF
THE SAME PROBLEMS THAT WERE YOU
MAY HEAR ABOUT TODAY.
NONE OF THEM HAPPENED ONCE YOU
IT WAS A LOT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON A. MANAGER
MOBILE HOME OF THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL COLLEGE
PLAYERS ASSOCIATION WHICH THE
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN. AND ETHICS COMMITTEE TO
VOTE YES.
BY THE NCA A. HAS PUBLICLY
DECLARED IT HAS NO DUTY TO
PROTECT. COLLEGE ATHLETES ARE TO
ENSURE BECAUSE ATHLETES ARE
QUITE EDUCATION.
THEN SAY WAS ALSO FOUND GUILTY
OF VIOLATING FEDERAL ANTITRUST
LAWS BY INSTITUTING AN ILLEGAL
PRICE FIXING SCHEME.
THE HARM TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE ATHLETES.
WHY WOULD THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOLLOW THE ANSWER
EASILY?
WHY WOULD ALLOW DANCE H.
PROHIBIT COLLEGES
FROM USING A PORTION OF REVENUES
FOR TO CREEK A DEGREE COMPLETION
FINE? OUTLINED THIS BILL.
ESPECIALLY WHEN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE AT THE GRADUATION RATES
RANK AMONG THE WORST IN THE
COUNTRY.
AFRICAN AMERICANS SUFFER
DISPROPORTIONATE NEGATIVE IMPACT
CLEMENTE LIMITS AS A MAKE UP THE
MAJORITY OF THE TEAM THAT
PRODUCED THE MOST REVENUE TO
SUFFER THE LOWEST GRADUATION
RATES.
THERE'S NO CREDIBLE REASON TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AFFECT IT'S
QUITE EASY TO DISCREDIT FALSE
ARGUMENTS A MESS AGAINST THIS
DEGREE COMPLETION FUN.
BUT A GROUNDBREAKING TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN STUDY
REVEALED A MORE SIGNIFICANT
FACTOR IN OPPOSING SUCH A
PROGRAM.
THE STUDY FOUND THAT RACIAL
RESENTMENT AGAINST AFRICAN
AMERICANS
IS THE PRIMARY FACTOR FUELING
THE OPPOSITION TO INCREASING
COMPENSATION FOR COLLEGE
ATHLETES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
NOT ALLOW UNDERLYING RACIAL
RESENTMENT TO INTERFERE WITH
PROGRESS TOWARD EQUAL RIGHTS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN CAN
EMPOWER CALIFORNIA COLLEGES TO
SOLVE GRADUATION RATE PROBLEMS
IT LEVY EIGHT RACIAL
DISPARITIES.
HELP PAY FOR MEDICAL EXPENSES
ASSOCIATED WITH EXTENSIVE
CHRONIC SPORTS INJURIES.
AND ADVANCE BECAUSE ATHLETES
TOWARD ECONOMIC FREEDOM THE
CALIFORNIA GRANTS OTHER STUDENTS
AND CITIZENS.
IF THIS BILL IS APPROVED
GRADUATION RATES WOULD SKYROCKET
PERIOD.
NANCY P. ASPIRATE YOUR YOUR YES
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DID WE HAVE TO WITNESS WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SO IT.
TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON I MANAGER
MARTINEZ THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
WE REALLY.
WERE OPPOSED THE BILL AS IT WAS
PUT ACROSS WITHIN. INTENDED BE
HEARD TODAY.
.
OBVIOUSLY THE BILL'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT AMEND ITS.
FOR THE GOOD OF THE AUTHOR. OUT
WE ARE STILL TRYING TO DIGEST OF
THE AMENDMENTS AND WHAT THEY
MEAN TO THE SYSTEM I THINK.
AT THIS POINT WE HAVE TO GET A
SENSE OF HOW THOUGH RULES ABOUT
THE ACCOUNT WHICH WOULD INTERACT
WITH THE NCA NOW THAT WOULDN'T
IMPACT OUR OBLIGATIONS TO OUR
STUDENT ATHLETES TO COMPETE. IN
ATHLETICS ARE THE CSU WE HAVE.
NINE DIVISION ONE SCHOOLS IN
TWELVE VISION TO SCHOOLS ARE
THAT ALL HAVE TO BE CAPTURED BY
THIS BILL.
I THINK OR THE OTHER BIG
CONCERN FOR THE CSU IS THE
MANDATORY REPORTING LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL.
BACK
CURRENTLY THE BILL AMENDS AT
SECTION TWO AT ALL.
STUDENT ATHLETES ROSA BEING OVER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN OR NOT.
AND IT SAYS THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
A NEW REPORT ANY ABUSE OR
NEGLECT THAT RESULT PERSON WOULD
BUT.
DEAN APPROPRIATE WE WERE ADDED
TO THE MANDATORY PART BECAUSE
SECTION BECAUSE THE SANDUSKY
EVENTS IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
PRIVATE BANKING BROUGHT. IT WAS
AWESOME INTERFERENCE TICKETS IN
THE HAVE THAT LANGUAGE TO THE
BILL.
BECAUSE THEIR KIDS EVER ON CSU
CAMPUSES IN THE SUMMERTIME ARE
YOU SEE OR ANY OF THE CAMPUSES
THAT WERE A ENGAGED ON THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND THERE MIGHT BE
SOME. EVENT THAT MIGHT TAKE
PLACE AND THAT SHOULD BE
REPORTED.
BUT SO BECAUSE OF THAT ALSO IF
YOU'LL PLEASE OR MANDATORY
PORTERS I MANDATORY BORDER.
TO SOME DEGREE.
BUT.
BECAUSE THAT MODIFICATION TO
LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR IT'S A SIX MONTH
PENALTY IT'S ABOUT DOLLAR FINE.
A I GUESS WHAT OF THE HOW THE
LANGUAGE GETS CHANGED WHEN IT
GETS AMENDED AND HOW THAT WORKS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS
CONCERNED GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
ERICA ROMERO ME HALF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING THE
PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT WE WERE
ALL SUPPOSED TO THE BILL AS IT
CAME ACROSS THE DESK.
AND WE DO UNDERSTAND OF COURSE
WE ARE WITH THIS ISSUE WE NEED A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO DIGEST
AND ALSO TO SEE THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE.
ALTHOUGH IT WAS REYES THAT IT'S
FALSE THAT THERE'S A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
INSTITUTIONS WHOSE BUDGETS ARE
UNDER A MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ATHLETICS. UP TO OUR LARGER
INSTITUTIONS ARE CURRENTLY
COVERED BY THE STUDENT ATHLETE
BILL OF RIGHTS.
AND IN OUR SECTOR THE CAL GRANT
DOESN'T COVER TUITION.
AND SO OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
STRUGGLING TO MEET THE FINANCIAL
NEED OF OUR NEEDIEST STUDENTS
AND WE SHOULD BE WORKING HARD TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. CAN ACCESS
PRIVATE HIGHER EDUCATION AND
SIMPLY ISSUE BECOMES.
DEPENDING ON HOW THIS
INSTRUCTED THAT THE INSTITUTIONS
ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR FINANCIAL MEDIA
STUDENTS MAY NOT CREATE THESE
FUNDS WERE OTHER INSTITUTIONS
MAY HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO SO.
AND SO IT DOES CREATE A
DISPIRITING AMONGST THE
INSTITUTIONS AS OUR INSTITUTIONS
STRUGGLE TO MEET FIRST THE NEEDS
OF FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS
WHETHER THEY'RE ATHLETES OR NOT.
AND SECONDLY RELATED TO THE
MANDATED REPORTER ISSUE AGAIN WE
NEED TO SEE.
THE LANGUAGE AS IT'S CRAFTED.
RIGHT NOW OUR. COACHES ARE AS
AND STUDENTS UNDER EIGHTEEN.
IF THERE IS A TITLE NINE
VIOLATIONS THAT SOMEBODY WAS
AWARE OF IF THERE'S A HARASSMENT
OR ASSAULT IT'S PROPERLY HANDLED
BY THE TITLE NINE OFFICES. WHO
ARE QUICK TO DO THIS AND OF
COURSE THERE'S ALSO OTHER TYPES
OF REPORTING UNDER CLEARY STOP
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
LANGUAGE TO SEE WHAT EXACTLY?
DOT LANGUAGE THAT'S.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JANET LOPEZ REPRESENTING
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ALLY MY COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AT THE TABLE
WE OPPOSED THE PERSIAN IMPRINTS
AND LOOK FOR DISSING THE
LANGUAGE MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
TYLER I DO ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE ECHO
THE CONCERNS THAT A I CEASE YOU
IN CS YOU RAISED I'M WE READ A
LETTER IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THAT'S IN PRINT. AND BUT WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE COMING OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND.
LOOK FOR TO WORKING ON IT IN
ADDITION TO THIS HEARING THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
BOB NAIL REPRESENTING STANFORD
UNIVERSITY MORE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY MUCH IMPROVED
BUT WE ARE READY TO WITHDRAW OUR
OPPOSITION. I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT STANFORD STUDENT ATHLETES
HAVE A BETTER GRADUATION RATE
DONE THE STUDENTS AS A WHOLE.
GIVE.
ANY COMMENT SIR.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MS BAKER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND.
WE HAVE SEE OTHERS NUMBERS
STAND UP TO CAL.
ATHLETES BUT WE'LL SAVE THAT FOR
ANOTHER HEARING.
.
I THINK THE MANDATED REPORTER
PROVISION ALONE IS ENOUGH OF A
REASON WHY I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL.
I DID I THINK THAT IS THE RIGHT
LANGUAGE TO HAVE AND I I HOPE IT
WON'T GET WEAKENED AS IT GOES TO
OTHER LOCATIONS I REALLY WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT BECAUSE IF IT
IS.
THERE MEMBERS WILL BE VERY VOCAL
IF IT IT IF IT IS WEAKENED.
I SHARE THE CONCERNS HOWEVER
PARTICULARLY THE.
OF THE OPPOSITION ABOUT THIS
FUND MEN THE FUND IS VERY I KNOW
WHAT IT'S GOING TO BE THE
LANGUAGE IS VERY PRECISE IS
UNUSUAL FOR US I THINK IS A
POLICY COMMITTEE DEBT. SO WHAT'S
SOMETHING OUT THAT THAT HAS.
IT IS THAT UNDETERMINED.
SOAK IT CERTAINLY KEEP AN EYE
ON IT I SIR HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
WORD ABOUT WHAT THE AMENDMENTS
WOULD BE I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT
YOU TO HOLD TO THAT IT'S JUST
I'M. HOLD STRONG ON THE MANDATED
REPORTER LANGUAGE AND AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN. GET SOME MORE
DETERMINATION THAT WHAT THIS
FUND WILL BE AND AND WHO AND HOW
WILL BE MANAGED WITH THE
CONCERNS AND YOU KNOW I'VE GOT
ST MARY'S COLLEGE MY DISTRICT
AND JUST THE INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT. COLLEGES ACROSS THE
STATE THAT I THINK ARE ARE VALID
CONCERNS.
SO THANK YOU AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE YOU KEEP STRONG WITH
THAT LANGUAGE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
HOLD. UP THE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE THE THE
COMMENTS AND YES WE WILL HOLD
FIRM ON THIS I KNOW THAT. HOW WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE CHAIR
AND I DO APPRECIATE HIS
ENGAGEMENT ALONG WITH STAFF
BECAUSE THERE WERE OTHER TO
OTHER?
VERY IMPORTANT PARTS TO THIS
THAT WE. ARE BELIEVED NEEDED TO
BE EXPLORED THEY WERE THEY WERE
INDEED.
CHALLENGING WE NEEDED TO HAVE.
.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO
SORT OF FIGURE OUT HOW TOWARD
ARCHITECT TO A STRATEGY AROUND
THEM. BUT I THINK THAT THESE TO
GIVE.
SEARCHED CERTAINLY WITH A
MANDATED REPORTER I THINK IT
REALLY DOES BEEF UP BECAUSE WE
HAVE ALREADY SEEN. INSTANCES OF
WHERE. A SOMETHING FELL THROUGH
THE CRACKS AND SO THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO.
A PLUG BET UP IN AN AS A REAL
PLACE TO THE OF THE FUND.
IT'S A MECHANISM THAT WE'RE
CREATING AND SCHOOLS WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
TO USE IT.
ARM AND DETERMINE HOW. TO USE IT
WHO AYE IF WE LOOK AT THE
O'BANNON CASE.
OF THAT IS NOT INCONSISTENT WITH
WHAT THE COURT HAD DETERMINE
THEIR FINDINGS.
HAD IT BEEN IN PLACE IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN AN EASIER PLACE FOR
THE JUDGE TO SAY HERE'S HOW YOU
WOULD PLUG IDEA.
AND HERE'S HOW IN THE CASE OF
THE LOWER COURT THE FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD BE.
HOW COULD BE HANDLED AND THIS
WOULD BE HELD IN TRUST UNTIL?
THE.
GRADUATION OR TILL THE THE
PLAYING TIME IS EXPIRED OF THE
ELIGIBILITY HAD RUN OUT. OF OR
THEY WOULD LOOKING TO EXTEND
THEIR EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
AND THERE WERE RESOURCES THERE
TO DRAW UPON. AND SO. I THINK
IT'S MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WE SCALED IT DOWN.
AND ARE I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEES HELP IN THAT
REGARD AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
YOUR.
AYE VOTE.
WELL I I WANNA THANK YOU OF THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. AND.
AND TO COMMUNICATE THAT.
AT THE COMMITTEE.
AS.
LOOKS TO YOU AS A RESOURCE
AS A FORMER STUDENT ATHLETE
YOURSELF.
AS A FATHER OF STUDENT ATHLETES.
WE KNOW YOUR YOUR.
.
INTEREST AND PASSION ON THIS
SUBJECT SO I THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL. AND I'M SYMPATHETIC
TO MANY THE EFFORTS THAT WERE
INITIALLY PROPOSED.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO VERY
REAL CHALLENGES.
THAT YOU BRING FORWARD.
BUT THANK YOU FOR AGREEING TO
TAKE THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
AND THE BILL WILL PROCEED TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY DOCTOR RUMBULA AND A
SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER.
THE MADAM SECRETARY BUTTE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DEEP PASSED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEDINA AYE
MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM.
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ NO IRWIN.
KILEY.
LEVINE.
LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
IT'S ONE THAT BILL WILL BE ON
CALL.
AND NOW WE WILL GO TO YOUR
SECOND BILL ITEM TEN A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE.
THAT WE.
SECOND.
IN THIS ENJOY SUPPORT SUPPORT.
AND DOES.
AND WITHOUT EMOTION OKAY AT
THAT.
ARE AND THE SECOND ALRIGHT GROW.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE.
YOUR SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY NINETY ONE.
IT'S WORK THAT CONTINUES.
AND I APPRECIATE ALSO MR MEDINA
I'M SORRY HAVE MISTER SANTIAGO.
WHO'S AGREED TO BE A JOINT
AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE. THEY ARE
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE
AUTHORIZED THE GOVERNOR BOB
GOVERNING BODY OF A CHARTER
SCHOOL TO ENTER INTO A COLLEGE
AND CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GOVERNING
BOARD. OF COMMITTEE COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
AND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
OCCURRED AB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH ENACTED MAJOR REFORM TO
ENSURE THAT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
COULD ACCESS COMMUNICABLE EDGE
COURSES THROUGH DUAL ENROLLMENT
PROGRAMS TO PREPARE THEM FOR
TRANSITION TO COLLEGE. THIS BILL
SIMPLY CREATES THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS AS OUR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU WOULD JUST ISN'T
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE FOOT
HELD THE ANSWER KERN. LAS RIOS
SAN DIEGO AND YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT I THINK YOUR
ANALYSIS DOESN'T EXCELLENT JOB.
OF LAYING OUT THE ISSUE AND AS
ONE WHO WAS INVOLVED INTIMATELY
IN THE NEGOTIATIONS OF AB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT IT WAS NEVER OUR
INTENT TO LEAVE OUT PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND. AND THIS
GIVES MORE STUDENTS ACCESS TO
DUAL ENROLLMENT WHICH HAS PROVEN
TO BE VERY BENEFICIAL FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WE WOULD URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DOMINIC
TOMARI HERE ABOUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE WE THANK THE
AUTHOR.
OF AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS
BILL WE.
WIPING INCLUDED AND SINCE IT HAS
SUPPORT SUPPORT OF AN EXERCISE
THE FIRST RULE OF LOVING WHICH
IS STOP DIGGING WHEN YOU STRIKE
WHERE SOME.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
RAYBURN ALLEN DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION FOR THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH AND I CALIFORNIA AND AS
LONG TIME SUPPORTER OF SEA
CAPTAIN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THAT EVER ON BEHALF OF ME
COLLEGE LEAGUE HERE IN SUPPORT.
RYAN CORNER WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER IS ON THIS BILL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE THE COMMITTEE.
MR HOLDER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. A FIGMENT SECURE SECULAR
SPHERE OF THANK YOU.
.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND.
THANK YOU FOR THAT OUT MAKING
SURE THAT AND UNDER REPRESENTED.
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE ALWAYS
INCLUDED SIR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THE
MOTION IS.
DO PASSED TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE BUT A MOTION BY MS
BAKER AND A SECOND BY DOCTOR
ARAMBULA. BAND CHAIR.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
KILEY.
LEVINE. LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WE WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT.
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO BEGIN WITH THE
ITEM FOR A. B. TWENTY TO TWENTY.
ABSOLUTELY.
COLLEGE AT THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AND YOUR STAFF AT THE PRINT THIS
MEASURE.
AB TWELVE TWENTY TO TWENTY WILL
EXPAND ON THE SIGNIFICANT
STRIDES MADE. BY THE STUDENT
ATHLETE BILL OF RIGHTS TO
PROTECT COLLEGE ATHLETES UNDER
CURRENT LAW. THE STUDENT AT THE
BILL OF RIGHTS ONLY APPLIES TO
INTERCOLLEGIATE ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS AT FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
THAT RECEIVED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE IN ANNUAL
REVENUE. DERIVED FROM METEORITES
FOR INTERCOLLEGIATE ATHLETICS
THIS MEANS ONLY COLLEGE ATHLETES
AT UCLA UC BERKELEY U. S. C..
AND STANFORD ARE PROTECTED UNDER
CURRENT LAW IS HAS CREATED TWO
TIER SYSTEM IN OUR STATE WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR COLLEGE ATHLETES
COLLEGE ATHLETES.
WHO HAVE PROTECTIONS UNDER THIS
DO NOTHING BILL OF RIGHTS FOR
HIS COLLEGE ATHLETES WHO
CONTINUE? TO LEAVE IT ALL ON THE
FIELD FOR THEIR SCHOOL WITHOUT A
GUARANTEE THAT THEIR SCHOOL
WOULD BE WILLING TO DO THE SAME
FOR THEM. CURRENTLY FORTY THREE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS WITH
COLLEGIATE ATHLETIC PROGRAMS IN
DIVISION ONE AND TO HAVE THE
AUTONOMY TO DETERMINE WHETHER TO
PAY FOR AN ATHLETE'S MEDICAL
EXPENSES. IF THE ATHLETE GETS
INJURED ADDITIONALLY COLLEGE
ATHLETES WHO GET INJURED DURING
PRACTICE OR GAME ARE NOT
PROTECTED FROM LOSING. THEIR
ATHLETIC SCHOLARSHIPS AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY WILL REQUIRE
INSTITUTIONS TO PAY THE
DEDUCTIBLE FOR COLLEGE ATHLETES
WHO SUFFER SPORTS RELATED
INJURIES AND FOR THE COST OF
ONGOING MEDICAL TREATMENT. FOR
AT LEAST TWO YEARS AFTER A
STUDENT HAS GRADUATED OR LEFT
THE UNIVERSITY.
A FURTHER AB TWENTY TO TWENTY
REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE AN
EQUIVALENT SCHOLARSHIP WITH THE
STUDENTS.
STUDENTS ATHLETIC SCHOLARSHIP IS
NOT RENEWED DUE TO THE INJURY.
WITH AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY WE CAN
GIVE A COLLEGE ATHLETES ACROSS.
CALIFORNIA THE ABILITY TO
SUCCEED BOTH IN THE CLASSROOM
AND IN THE FIELD AFTER ALL THEY
ARE STUDENT ATHLETES.
STUDENTS FIRST ATHLETE SECOND WE
ARE NOT TURN OUR BACKS ON
COLLEGE ATHLETES IN THE MOMENTS
WHEN THEY NEED US MOST.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL THAT WILL EXPAND.
THE ARABS DO NOTHING BILL OF
RIGHTS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT.
HER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES WITH ME
HERE TODAY IS REMOTELY HOA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL COLLEGE PLAYERS
ASSOCIATION.
OUR THANK YOU AGAIN.
SO THE NASA BECAUSE PLAYERS
THOSE ISSUE THE SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY.
NASA'S COMMITTEE FOR YES YES
VOTE.
OUR A RECENT STUDY REVEALED THAT
SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT OF COLLEGE
ATHLETES SUSTAIN A MAJOR COLLEGE
SPORTS INJURY.
AND FIFTY PERCENT OF COLLEGE
ATHLETES WILL SUFFER FROM
CHRONIC SPORTS INJURIES.
THESE ARE OTHERWISE SOME OF THE
HEALTHIEST PEOPLE ON THE PLANET.
THE PLAYING SPORTS FOR
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES PERFECT
PERSON AT SIGNIFICANT RISK.
UNDER NCAA RULES COLLEGES CAN
FORCE PLAYERS TO PAY THE MEDICAL
EXPENSES.
SPORTS RELATED INJURIES CAN EVER
DIRECT NEGATIVE EFFECT ON A
PLAYER'S ABILITY TO GRADUATE.
AND UNDER NCAA RULES COLLEGES
CAN REFUSE TO RENEW AN ATHLETIC
SCHOLARSHIP FOR PERMANENTLY
INJURED PLAYERS.
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT GRADUATION A PROBLEM
THEIR RANKS AMONG THE WORST IN
THE NATION.
EIGHTY ONE OF CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
TEAMS ACROSS TWENTY NINE
DIVISION ONE AND DIVISION TWO
COLLEGES HAVE GRADUATION RATES
BELOW SIXTY PERCENT.
WITH AN AVERAGE GRADUATION RATE
OF FORTY FIVE PERCENT.
CALIFORNIA DIVISION ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO COLLEGES HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THESE
PROBLEMS.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND THREE IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN DIVISION TO
REVENUE AMONG CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES INCREASED FROM
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL REVENUE.
THIS IS A REVENUE INCREASE OF
SIX HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE PERCENT.
NOTABLY PARTICIPATION ONLY
INCREASE FORTY SIX PERCENT.
CALIFORNIA DIVISION ONE COLLEGS
AND ENJOYED A REVENUE INCREASE
OF FOUR HUNDRED SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS DURING THIS TIME PERIOD.
WHAT PARTICIPATION NUMBERS
ACTUALLY DECREASED BY ELEVEN
PERCENT?
THESE COLLEGES CAN AFFORD
PROVIDES PROJECTIONS.
THERE'S NO BETTER PLACE TO
DIRECT SOME OF THIS WINDFALL
REVENUE THAT TO GRADUATE AND
GUARANTEE MEDICAL SERVICES FOR
THE PLAYERS WHOSE BODIES ARE
BROKEN BY GENERATING THIS MONEY
FOR THE COLLEGES. BECKY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER WHO'S.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERICA ROMERO
BEHALF THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING
THE PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS IN THE STATE.
AND WE ARE RESPECTFULLY COME
VISIT YOUR LOCAL NONPROFIT
INSTITUTION AND VISIT OUR SPORTS
DEPARTMENTS AND SEE HOW WE TAKE
CARE FIRST IT.
THE SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF OUR
STUDENTS IS PARAMOUNT TO US AND
WE TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY
UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE SUIT
ATHLETE BILL OF RIGHTS. AND
REMOVING THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR
CAP.
YOU'RE PLAYING THIS TO ANY
INSTITUTION THAT OFFERS AN
ATHLETIC SCHOLARSHIP.
AND AS WE TALK ABOUT REVENUES
WANT TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
ONE OF OUR INSTITUTIONS WHEN WE
REPORT REVENUES TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND PRO REQUIRED TO
DO SO. IT JUST SOUNDS REVENUE SO
WE ASK WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
ON ONE CAMPUS REVENUES THE WAY
WE THINK ABOUT IT ITS TERMS OF
ATHLETICS SALES TICKET SALES. IS
TWENTY THOUSAND OAKS.
THE REST OF THE MONEY TO MILLION
DOLLARS IS FROM GREECE BY THE
CAMPUS TO ALLOW THE STUDENTS TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN CAMPUS SPORTS.
IT'S ALL FUN GREATEST.
AND SO AS YOU INCREASE COSTS TO
INSTITUTIONS THERE IS GOING TO
BE A TREAT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO BELIEVE INSTITUTIONS CAN JUST
KEEP FUNDRAISING WE HAVE OTHER
COSTS WE FUNDRAISE FOR AS WELL.
FOR SCHOLARSHIPS FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE CAPITAL OUTLAY
WHICH THE STATE DOES NOT FUND
AND THESE PROGRAMS ARE VERY
SMALL.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL ACTUALLY
CAPTURES INSTITUTIONS THAT DON'T
PLAY IN THE NC DOUBLE A.
THERE ARE SEVENTEEN INSTITUTIONS
FIFTEEN OF THEM BELONG AND
PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT OUT WHEN
YOU SEE ONCE IT'S YOU. WHO PLAY
IN THE NBA? AND THE AVERAGE
CAMPUS SIZE IS UNDER A THOUSAND
STUDENTS FOR THESE
AND YET THERE ARE GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO PLAY UNDER THE SAME
RULES.
IN DIVISION TWO IN ADDITION
THERE ARE NO MULTI YEAR
SCHOLARSHIPS.
UNTIL RECENTLY THEY WERE NOT
ACTUALLY TO GIVE OUT
SCHOLARSHIPS EVEN FOR THE FULL
YEAR IT WAS IN RECOGNITION OF
THE SIZE OF THE BUDGETS OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS.
AND SO ESSENTIALLY UNDER THE
SPELL WE ARE INCREASING COSTS
BECAUSE WE SAVE YOUR INTERVIEWER
NOW GUARANTEED THE SCHOLARSHIP.
AND SO REMEMBERING THAT
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS GRADUATE WE TAKE
THEIR SAFETY VERY SERIOUSLY. BUT
AT INSTITUTIONS AGAIN WHERE WE
DON'T WE NEED THIS COULD MEAN
YOU TAKE THE SCHOLARSHIP FROM A
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENT WHEN
THE STUDENT TO NOT HAVE MADE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANGIE MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
WE TOO MUST BE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
THIS WOULD MAKE ALL OF THE
TWENTY ONE.
SCHOOLS OF THE CSU THAT OFFERED
DIVISION ONE TO SCHOOLS GOT
CAPTURED BY IT SAFER. BUSTER
MATHIS BILL OF RIGHTS.
THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION WILL
POINT THAT SAN DIEGO STATE MAY
HAVE BEEN CAPTURED BY THE
ORIGINAL. TO THE BILL BUT THEY
NEVER WERE CLOSE TO THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. IN MEDIA
REVENUE THEY WORK AT BEST TO THE
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN MEDIA
REVENUE I THINK THAT AT THAT.
WHEN YOU THINK OF CSU SPORTS
INDIGO STATE FRESNO STATE THOSE
ARE THE BIG TWO SPORTS PROGRAMS
AT THE CSU AND THERE ARE FAR
BEHIND WHERE THE OTHER ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS ARE.
YOU THINK OF WHEN YOU THINK OF
THE STRONG ROBUST AFFECT
PROGRAMS NATIONALLY.
SO OF THE CSU CAMPUSES AGAIN WE
HAVE NINE DIVISION ONE INTO A
TWELVE DIVISION TO ATHLETICS.
AND THIS BILL IN ADDITION TO THE
REPLACEMENT SCHOLARSHIP FOR
INJURED ATHLETES THIS WOULD
REQUIRE US TO GIVE A REPLACEMENT
SCHOLARSHIP FOR THE FIFTH YEAR
FOR STUDENTS WHO GRADUATED.
THAT IS GOING TO COME OUT OF THE
BUDGET OF THE DIVISION TWO
SCHOOLS WHICH IS OPERATING NOT
OFF MEDIA REVENUES BUT OFF OF.
FUND RAISING OFF OF A. STUDENT
FEES.
AT THAT SUPPORT THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE OPERATING ON A
SHOESTRING BUDGET THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE A COST TO THE SYSTEM
TO MANAGE. AND IT WASN'T.
JUST LOST LAST FALL A C. IS YOU
HUMBOLDT WAS CONSIDERING
SHUTTING DOWN FOOTBALL THOSE
DIVISION TO PROGRAM.
THAT IS JUST HOW CLOSE THEY
WERE TO CONSIDERING WHAT HOW DO
WE MEASURE BUDGET HOW WE MANAGED
THE EXPENDITURES. AND PAY FOR
ALL THOSE EXTRA EXPENSES.
.
IN ADDITION WE'RE ALSO REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEY WERE THE
RIGHT OF ACTION IN THE BILL OF
DEBTS CAN EXPOSE A STRAWBERRY
LITIGATION AND IT'S IT'S GOING
TO GROUP PARTICIPATE FOR THE
ATTORNEY FIGHT CAR FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE. PUBLISHED A
SABRE AND ANY BAD PENALTIES THAT
THE COURT DECIDES IT TO BEYOND
APPROPRIATE THAT AGAIN BECAUSE
OF THE BUDGET OF THE OPERATING
FOR THE ETHICS PROGRAMS AS WELL
THAT THOSE OF THE OF THE REASON
WHY MUST BE OPPOSED THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY IN. FORM.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JANET LOPEZ REPRESENTING
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WERE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION SPECIFICALLY AROUND
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN THE BILL
THINKING.
TYLER I DO ARMY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
DO HAVE TO SCHOOLS THAT FULLY
COMPLY WITH THE S..
SP SEEN BILL OF RIGHTS SOON
ATHLETE BILL OF RIGHTS UC
BERKELEY AND CAL BUT APPLYING
THIS TO OUR INSTITUTIONS WOULD
BE PROBLEMATIC FOR THE REASONS
THAT CSU ANY I SEE CEO.
HIGHLIGHTED SO WE REMAIN
OPPOSED THE BILL THANK YOU.
BOB NAYLOR REPRESENTING STANFORD
UNIVERSITY WERE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL THANKS AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
STIR BONTA WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
CLOSE.
YES IT YOU KNOW I I'M APPRECIATE
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS ABOUT
COST AND WE CONTINUE TO INVITE
AT A CONVERSATION THAT IS.
A A SPECIFIC CONVERSATION ABOUT
ACTUAL COSTS THAT WOULD BE
INCURRED.
FROM THIS BILL WE'VE DEATHLY
HEARD.
THE BROAD CONCERNS THAT THE
THEORETICAL ADDITIONAL COSTS.
BEEN SUGGESTED AND ALSO A YOU
KNOW GENERAL ARE REFERENCES TO
INCREASE COSTS BUT. BUT I'M I
REALLY LIKE TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
IT THAT THE DATA AROUND AT
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE WHO HAVE ON
SCHOLARSHIP OF GOT INJURED. AND
HOW THAT'S LED TO INCREASE COSTS
AND THEN ONCE WE HAVE THAT I
THINK THE DATA CAN HELP. HELP
GENERATE THE SOLUTION BUT. TO BE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR CLEAR OVER TALK
ABOUT HERE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR ATHLETES THAT
HAVE BEEN BUDGETED.
THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN BY THE
SCHOOLS.
TO AN INDIVIDUAL IN THEIR BUDGET
THEY WANTED TO GIVE IT THEY HAVE
THE MONEY FOR IT THEY RAISE THE
MONEY FOR IT.
AND.
SO WHERE IS THE ADDITIONAL COST
IT JUST SAYING IF THAT PERSON
GETS HURT.
DON'T TAKE IT AWAY FROM THEM
THEY'VE MADE LIFE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHERE TO GO TO SCHOOL AND
WHAT WHAT THEY CAN AFFORD BASED
ON THE SCHOLARSHIP THAT'S BEEN
OFFERED TO THEM.
AND SO.
THERE STUDENT.
GRADUATE FROM THEIR YOUTH FOR
THEM INSTITUTION DON'T TAKE IT
AWAY FROM THEM DON'T TURN YOUR
BACK ON THEM BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
PLAY. ON YOUR SPORTS FIELD EVEN
THOUGH THEY'LL STILL BE IN YOUR
CLASSROOM.
THE ONLY ADDITIONAL CASA BE IF
THEY DECIDE THAT THEY WANT A TO
OFFER AN ADDITIONAL SCHOLARSHIP
THAT YEAR. FEAR NEITHER HAVE
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR WOMEN SOCCER.
AND YOU GIVE THEM ALL UP AND ONE
PERSON GETS INJURED.
YOU STILL PAY FOR NINE AND HAVE
SCHOLARSHIPS YOU HAVE EIGHT
EIGHT IT YOU KNOW YOU HAD HAVE
MET MANY PEOPLE PLAYING. YOU
MIGHT NOT BE OF GIVEN ADDITIONAL
SCHOLARSHIP MIGHT HAVE TO SPREAD
THE EXISTING SCHOLARSHIPS OUT SO
THAT THEY'RE NOT A HUNDRED
PERCENT THE COULD BE NINETY
PERCENT. BUT THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL COSTS
UNLESS YOU'RE SAYING YOU MUST
HAVE THE RIGHT.
STRIP AN INDIVIDUAL OF THEIR
SCHOLARSHIP AND OFFER TO SOMEONE
ELSE.
IT AND AND AND AND THAT YOU
DON'T WANT TO GIVE IT TO TO THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS BEEN HURT
THEIR HURT PLAYING A SPORT THAT
YOU INVITED THEM TO AND
RECRUITED THEM TO AND ONE OF
THEM TO AT YOUR AT YOUR FIELD.
ARE AT YOUR SCHOOL. COULD BE
THROUGH NO FAULT OF YOUR OWN
ACCIDENTS HAPPEN SPORTS I KNOW
THAT FIRST HAND.
SO.
WE NEED THAT MAKES YOU HAVE OUR
PRIORITIES RIGHT HERE. THAT WERE
SUPPORTING ACADEMIC SUCCESS OF
OUR STUDENT ATHLETES NOT JUST
ATHLETIC SUCCESS IN THAT WE
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS THROUGH
GRADUATION THAT AT THIS BILL
SEEKS TO DO. I THINK IT STRIKES
AB BUT A GOOD BALANCE AND WE
HAVE A ONGOING OPEN MINDEDNESS
TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES WE HAVE HEARD ANY
YET.
I AND SO WHEN WE DO OUR WE ARE
VERY EXCITED TO TO HELP PROVIDE
A SOLUTION.
IT'S THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
WE'VE ALSO SAID WE DON'T NEED A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION WE JUST
NEED SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
ENFORCEABILITY THAT CAN'T BE
AYE.
OPTIONAL THING THIS NEEDS TO BE
SOMETHING WHERE IF I STUDENTS
NOT TREATED RIGHT AND THIS THIS
DO NOT THE BILL OF RIGHTS IS
NOT.
ENFORCED THAT DATE THEY HAVE
SOME A RECOURSE DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE PART RIGHT PRIDE RIGHT OF
ACTION I THINK I BELIEVE THAT
WE'VE INVITED A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THAT HAVEN'T HEARD. OTHER
OPTIONS YET WE CONTINUE TO
INVITE THAT CONVERSATION
CONTINUE TO BE OPEN MINDED ABOUT
DIFFERENT WAYS TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOU I VOTED
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA.
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
MOVED BY MISTER LEVINE SECOND BY
DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD AYE AYE HAS SUPPORTED
THE BILL AN ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT.
COMMITTEE AND I'M HAPPY TO US
SUPPORTED AGAIN TODAY.
TIME SECRETARY WHO WOULD CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION AS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM CHáVEZ.
CHAVEZ NO IRWIN. KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE AYE LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
IT'S ONE A THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
AND WE HAVE A ITEM SIXTY.
A. B. THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES TO FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT MY SECOND
BILL TODAY A. B. THIRTY TWO
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
THAT STAFF HAS PUT INTO IT.
IT THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN WOULD
ESTABLISH MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS
FOR UC'S NCS USE AND PRIVATE
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS TO
ACCOUNT FOR IN A STUDENTS COST
TO ATTEND THE ACADEMIC
INSTITUTION THE GOAL HERE IS TO
REALLY HAVE.
THAT THE COST OF ATTENDANCE.
MATCH THE ACTUAL COSTS THAT A
STUDENT IS GOING TO.
.
IN ENSURE AND FACE WENT WOMEN
IN.
SCHOOL AND IN COLLEGE RIGHT NOW
WE SEE A LOT THERE'S A LOT OF
HIDDEN COSTS A LOT OF UNEXPECTED
COSTS.
THAT ARE BURDEN A STUDENT
BECAUSE IT WASN'T IN AT THE COST
OF ATTENDANCE SO A. WE WANNA
THAT I CHANGE THAT HAVE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE COST OF ATTENDANCE
LOOK.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE PROPOSE IN
AB THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN SO I AM I
HAVE IT WITH ME TODAY MAGGIE
WHITE STUDENT TRUSTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY TO
PROVIDE SOME TESTIMONY.
UNDER* HERE I GET AFTERNOON
EVERYONE THINK IF AS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. AND MY
NAME IS MAGGIE Y. MST* HE
STANISLAUS TESTING AMERICA THE
CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND A
PRIVILEGE TO BE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND. REPRESENT
NEARLY HALF MILLION STUDENTS OF
THE CSU SYSTEM.
AT THE COST OF COLLEGE HAS
INCREASED FINANCIAL AID HAS NOT
KEPT PACE AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
HARMED.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO UP TO DATE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE FULL COST
OF ATTENDANCE WHICH EXTENDS FAR
BEYOND THE PRICE OF TUITION.
THIS PROPOSED FORMULA AS
ESSENTIAL SECTIONS THE TOTAL
COST ESTIMATE INCLUDING
TECHNOLOGY TRANSPORTATION AND
DEPENDING COST LIKE CHILD CARE.
WE KNOW THAT THESE COSTS ARE
VERY REAL AND AFFECTS STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE IN THEIR
ABILITY TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION.
ACKNOWLEDGING THE REALITY OF THE
COST OF COLLEGE ATTENDANCE WILL
INCREASE EQUITY AND IMPROVE
STUDENT SUCCESS.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SPELL
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER.
COME THE TWO WINNERS.
ERICA ROMERO BEHALF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE HAVE SHARED SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE.
WHENCE WE INCLUDE SOMETHING AND
COST OF ATTENDANCE WE HAVE TO
PACKAGE THE STUDENT OBVIOUSLY WE
WANT TO GIVE THEM ACCURATE
BECAUSE. WE ARE ALL VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS YEAR'S
SURVEY PROVIDING UNIFORM
INFORMATION TO ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION.
VICTOR CONCERN DOES.
A CURRY AND IN A DIVERSE SECTOR
FOR INSTANCE IN SOME OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS WE DON'T ACTUALLY
HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE.
POLICIES AND SO HOW DO WE LIST
THAT I'M FOR EXTRA CURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES.
THE EXAMPLE THAT WAS GIVEN TO
US IS THAT WOULD CROSS WHICH IS
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IS OUT OF.
THE REACH OF SOME STUDENTS
HOWEVER ONCE WE PROVIDE ALONE
CHU STUDENT. WE CAN'T TAKE IT
BACK AND SO IT INCREASES
POTENTIAL DEBT BURDEN THEY CAN
COME TO APPEAL TO THE SUPREME
WHAT TO PLAY AN EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITY.
HOWEVER BECAUSE WE BUDGETED UP
FRONT WHAT HAPPENS IS WE START
WITH OUR LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS.
AND AS YOU GO UP THE INCOME
SCALE YOU GET A LARGER GAP
BECAUSE WE HAD TO PUT THE SAME
AMOUNT IN FOR EVERY STUDENT
WHETHER OR NOT HE DID IT. I'M
MORE HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE THANK YOU.
THE AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX
GRAVES OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL.
I THINK WE WOULD.
AGREE WITH MUCH OF CON WHAT'S
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT IS A RELATES TO
THIS BILL.
WE ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO THE
INFORMATION THAT IS BEING
GATHERED THROUGH THIS YEAR STUDY
CURRENTLY BEING CARRIED OUT BY
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION. I
AND WE THINK THAT THAT WILL BE A
USEFUL CONSUMER INFORMATION TOOL
FIVE FOR STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AS THEY TRY TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH COLLEGE GOING
TO COST AND WHERE THEY WANT TO
GO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YEAH AFTERNOON TYLER RIGHT YOU
ARE IN BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE ONE
SPECIFIC CONCERN AROUND THE
FREQUENCY OF FINANCIALLY
DISBURSEMENTS.
AND WE'VE REYES THAT.
AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN.
TOPIC OF DISCUSSION BUT WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE BILL
AND.
WORK AT THE OTHERS OFFICE THANK
YOU.
I BY NO SORRY I'M AN
UNDERGRADUATE USED TO BERKELEY
BOARD MEMBER OF THE UNIVERSITY
COP Y. STUDENTS ASSOCIATION AND
WHERE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND
YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
A.
DOCTOR WEBER.
BOB JUST THAT I WOULD IMPACT
DOES THIS HAVE ON THE OVERALL
BUDGET FOR FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FOR STUDENTS.
WE KNOW.
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE IS IS YOU
TO DETERMINISTIC OF FINANCIAL
AID PACKAGE UNITS AT THE UPPER
LIMIT ON ON HOW MUCH FEDERAL
STATE AND INSTITUTIONAL FINER
FINANCIAL AID A STUDENT CAN
RECEIVE SO. THIS WILL BECAUSE
EIGHT EIGHT.
AS A MORE APT ACCURATE
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT OF THAT
ALL THE CASA STUDENTS GONNA FACE
WHILE IN.
COLLEGE IT IT WILL RAISE THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR FINANCIAL AID TO
HIGHER AMOUNTS.
AND I'M SICK AND COULD LEAD TO
HIGHER FINANCIAL AID PACKAGES
RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE CERTAIN THINGS ARE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION AS COST
OF ATTENDING COLLEGE OF STUDENTS
ARE GETTING LOWER. OUR AMOUNTS
OF OF SUPPORT UNLESS THINGS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE PAID FOR AND THEN
WHEN THEY SAY WHEN THEY SEE THAT
THEY NEED TRANSPORTATION TO GET
HOME DURING. OUR THE WINTER
BREAK WHEN THE UNIVERSITY CLOSED
OR OR OR DURING THE SUMMER OR
THEY NEED A LAPTOP TO THEIR
SCHOOL WORK AND TO HAVE ACADEMIC
SUCCESS IN THE CAN'T USE TO
FINANCIAL AID FOR THAT. THAT
CREATES A PROBLEM LEADS TO KIDS.
YOUNG PEOPLE WORKING MORE HOURS
WHICH IMPACTS THEIR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS OR MAYBE EVEN DROP OUT
OF SCHOOL WHICH CERTAINLY
IMPACTS ACADEMIC SUCCESS SO. IT
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
MORE ROBUST FINANCIAL SUPPORT
THAT REALLY MATCHES THE COSTS OF
COLLEGE DOES THAT DOES THAT THEN
MEAN THAT FEWER STUDENTS WILL
RECEIVE FINANCIAL SYSTEM.
IF THE AMOUNT THAT ONE STUDENT
RECEIVED HIS HIGHER.
THAN WHAT WE HAVE NOW DOES THAT
MEAN I MEAN SO MUCH TO TALK
ABOUT THESE FINANCIALLY POT IS
IF THEIR NEVER ENDING THAT THEY
EXIST. AND THAT THERE IS A
FINITE NUMBER THAT'S THE AMOUNT
THAT WE DO SO THERE'S THIS
MEANS.
FEWER STUDENTS WILL GET
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE BUT THOSE
WHO GET IT THEY GET AT A HIGHER
RATE THAT'S A QUESTION.
I DON'T KNOW BUT.
I I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THE
LOGIC AND THE LICKED THE
CONCEPTUAL.
AND HOUSES AND BUILT INTO THE
QUESTION.
IT COULD BE THAT BECAUSE THE
COST FOR STUDENTS ARE GOING
HIGHER THAN THAN.
CERTAIN UNIVERSITIES WITH
RESOURCES WELL WONDERFULLY FUN
THE FINANCIAL AID.
IT COULD BE IF THEY'RE IN
FINANCIAL STRAITS THAT THEY
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO FUNDED AS
FROM MORE ABOUT HIS PAST AS
ROBUST AS POSSIBLE BUT THIS
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR IT
TO BE FUNDED. AND AND AND MORE
ROBUST WAYS FOR FOR STUDENTS.
WHENEVER YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SORT OF ZERO SIMON AND LIMITED
PIES THEN.
THEN YOUR YOU KNOW YOUR
QUESTION.
COULD RAISE CONCERN BUT WE HOPE
THAT FINANCIAL AID WILL GROW
WITH THE INCREASING ELIGIBILITY
IN THIS BILL.
OKAY I AM.
I FIND THIS INTRIGUING AND AND
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO BE AS
SUPPORTIVE AS I CAN I'LL I'LL BE
SUPPORTIVE TODAY I WANNA. PARTY
TALKS TO MY FOLKS IN FINANCIAL
AID IS FIND OUT EXACTLY WHAT THE
IMPACT IS. ON THAT SOME AREAS I
AGREE AT THE CENTRAL I'M I'M
FROM OLD SCHOOL SOUL IT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITY BUT YOU HAVE THE
CURRICULA ACTIVITY I'M HAPPY.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE CLASS AND
BOOKS AND STUFF YOU NEED SOME
NOT SURE IF THAT IS YOU KNOW I.
I THINK THERE'S A THERE'S A
THERE'S A.
THERE IS A COST OF GOING TO
SCHOOL NOT ONLY THE FINANCIAL
PART BUT THE PERSONAL PART AS
WELL. AND I OFTENTIMES IT SEEMS
AS IF I STUDENTS WANTED ALL.
AND I KNOW THE FOLKS WHO DIDN'T
GET IT ALL BUT GOT ENOUGH WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT IS TO GET THE
TUITION PAID FOR THE BOOKS THEIR
LODGING. AND AND FOOD AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS WOULD COULD THEY
JOIN A TEAM OF LACROSSE OR
WHATEVER.
PROBABLY NOT YOU KNOW AT THAT
POINT WAS TO GET A SCHOLARSHIP
OR. WHERE WE PAYING FOR THEIR
BOWLING NIGHT OUT WHICH STUDENTS
SOMETIMES LIKE TO DO PROBABLY
NOT I MEAN? YOU KNOW THERE'S A
PRICE YOU PAY FOR BEING A
STUDENT OFTENTIMES AND NOT DO
SHE SUFFERED BECOME HOMELESS IS
WE HAVE SOME SITUATIONS AND
HUNGRY. BUT I'M NOT SURE IF ALL
OF THIS FACTORS INTO WHAT I
THINK PERSONALLY THAT THE STATE
OUGHT TO BE FUNDING FOR STUDENTS
TO GO TO COLLEGE THAT THAT'S THE
ONLY THING. SO.
.
NOW SUPPORTED AND I AM CONCERNED
SOMETIMES THAT THAT WE'VE RUN
OUT OF MONEY.
BUT SOME SOME AND THEREFORE SOME
STUDENTS DON'T GET MONEY FOR.
TUITION AND BOOKS IN THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO HAVE
BECAUSE THERE IS A THERE IS A
POT OF MONEY AND THE MORE YOU
FUND THE MORE YOU GIVE WAY.
IT'S GONE AND SOME CAMPUSES ARE
DON'T HAVE FINANCIAL SYSTEMS AND
MARCUS I GAVE IT ALL OUT. I
WOULD HATE TO THINK THAT WE GIVE
HIGHER NUMBERS AND FACTOR IN
THESE OTHER THINGS AND NOT TAKE
YOUR THE BASICS SO. I'LL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF DAVE AB I WON AND
I HAVE TO LOOK AND SEE. WHAT
IMPACT FINANCIAL IMPACT THIS
WOULD HAVE ON THE OVERALL POT
AND THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO
WERE ABLE TO SIR?
I I REALLY APPRECIATE AS ALWAYS
YOUR YOUR INSIGHT DOCTOR WEBER
ON MANY ISSUES CERTAINLY AND
WHEN IT COMES TO HIGHER
EDUCATION POLICY. THAT THEY
ARGUED YOU'VE JUST MADE AND THAT
OTHERS HAVE MADE ABOUT THE EXTRA
QUICK THE COMPONENT THE BILL IS
IS REALLY. I'M RAISING QUESTIONS
WITH ME AND AND AND AND CREATING
AN OPTION FOR SOME SOME SELF
REFLECTION AND I THINK IT'S AN
AREA WHERE WHERE WHERE. OPEN TO
SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
GOING FORWARD GOOD I I'D LIKE TO
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE I I DON'T
WANNA STUDENT.
S. POURS OUR STUDENTS ARE DON'T
WANT TO STUDENT NOT HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED IN TERMS OF BOOKS AND
TUITION AND WHAT HAVE YOU. HAVE
SUPPORT KIDS LOCKED OUT BECAUSE
WE DECIDED THAT SOME OF THE KEY
IT LIKE TO DO A LOT OF
EXTRACURRICULAR STUFF. AND UP
YOU KNOW I ALWAYS BELIEVED YOU
KNOW GET THE CURRICULA STEP
CORRECT AND THE OTHER THINGS AND
AND YOU KNOW YOU COULD MAKE THE
CAN DO SOME OF THESE THINGS
OCCASIONALLY. BUT ANYWAY I I'LL
SUPPORT FOR NOT THAT THINK WE DO
NEED TO HAVE A REALISTIC VIEW OF
IT. I'M THINKING MORE IN TERMS
OF A REALISTIC WITH THE GOSSIP.
OF THE COST OF HOUSING IN
CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS AND MUCH
MORE THAN SOMEWHERE ELSE YET AND
THAT'S WHAT CAUSES A LOT OF KIDS
BECOME HOMELESS BECAUSE.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO LIVE AROUND
YOU SEE AS THE GOD A LAWYER
SOLOS IN THE STUDENTS THAT HAVE
LIVE FAR AWAY TAKE TRANSLATION
OR THEY DON'T HAVE HOUSING AT
ALL SO. I KNOW THAT THAT'S A
REALITY FOR A LOT OF CAMPUSES
ALLOW STUDENTS TO COST OF LIVING
IS IS RATHER HIGH BECAUSE OF THE
HOUSING THAT'S IN THE COMMUNITY.
THOSE OF REALISTIC THINGS WE
NEED TO LOOK AT FOR STUDENTS.
AND I AND I THINK THOSE THAT'S
IMPORTANT WE DO BEGIN TO HAVE A
REALLY SKEWED VIEW OF CAMPUS BY
CAMPUS IN TERMS OF WHAT IT TAKES
TO LIVE THEE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
WILLING TO TO LOOK AT THE EXTRA
CURRICULAR. THANK YOU MISTER RUN
TO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANKS FOR THE DISCUSSION AFFECT
WE ASK DRIVE OUT.
MISTER BONTA I UNDERSTAND THE
GOLDEN INTENT OF YOUR BILL.
I AND I SURE BUT I DO SHARE THE
CONCERNS IS LAID OUT ON PAGES
FOUR TO SIX OF THE IN THE
HOUSES.
I THINK SUMMER'S SIMILAR TO
THOSE EXPRESSED BY DOCTOR WEBER
I AM ALSO COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT IF
THE ISSUES RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS OF NOT BEEN ADDRESSED.
BY THE TIME THE BILL REACHES THE
FLOOR I RESERVE MY RIGHT TO VOTE
DIFFERENTLY. ONCE IT REACHES THE
FLOOR SO I WOULD.
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THE STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE A MOTION BY
DOCTOR RUMBULA AS SECOND BY
MISTER LOWE. AND MADAM SECRETARY
OF THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE PEOPLE
CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE. BAKER.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
CHAVEZ.
SHOP WITH NOT BOATING IRWIN.
KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW AYE PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
FIVE ZERO IT'S ON CALL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
SO NEXT WE HAVE A ITEM FOURTEEN
MS CUTTY ó.
A. B. THIRTY ONE OR ONE
.
WELCOME MISGUIDED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN.
I GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
HERE TO PRESENT A. B. THIRTY ONE
OH ONE. A MEASURE TO SIMPLIFY
THE LENGTHY AND COMPLICATED.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE APPLICATION
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WITH THE CURRENT FETHIYE APPLY
APPLICATION AS LONG CONFUSING.
AND OCCASIONALLY INTRUSIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE STUDENTS SPEND AN AVERAGE
OF OVER AN HOUR COMPLETING THE
APPLICATION FOR ADMISSION. TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THE QUESTIONS ARE OFTEN
REPETITIVE OR UNNECESSARY SUCH
AS RESIDENTIAL QUESTIONS TO
DETERMINE. TUITION LEVELS FOR
NON CREDIT STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT
REQUIRED.
TO PAY TUITION
WHILE COMMUNITY COLLEGE ACROSS
THE STATE RECOGNIZE THIS PROBLEM
AND HAVE WRITTEN TO MY OFFICE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE TOOK IT
UPON OURSELVES TO LOOK INTO THE
APPLICATION.
WE WERE SHOCKED THAT IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THE MAILING
INFORMATION PORTION THE FIRST
QUESTION ON THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION SECTION. OFTEN ARE
AT ACTUALLY OUT POTENTIAL
STUDENTS TO CHOOSE AN OPTION FOR
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY AND THEIR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
WE WE'RE BEING ASKED TO PICK
BETWEEN STRAIGHT GAY LESBIAN
BISEXUAL OTHER DECLINE TO STATE
BEFORE EVEN IN PUTTING ANYTHING
RELATED TO A HIGH SCHOOL GPA.
WHILE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
STATE THAT OFFICE THEY WANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE BACKGROUND OF OUR
APPLICANTS.
SUCH ABRUPT QUESTIONS ABOUT
CITIZENSHIP GENDER OR RACE
ETHNICITY FEEL. TACTICALLY AT A
PLACE.
THE APPLICATION SHOULD FEEL LIKE
A WELCOMING FIRST STEP.
TO AN INDIVIDUAL'S ACADEMIC
JOURNEY. NOT AN INTERROGATION
OVER FIVE PERCENT OF STUDENTS DO
NOT FINISH THE APPLICATION. BUT
WITH MILLIONS OF STUDENTS
APPLYING EVERY YEAR THIS MEANS
THAT WE LOSE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF GRADUATES IN FUTURE
WORKERS.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
AND I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
COLLABORATE LEAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
STREAMLINE THE APPLICATION. OF
THE APPLICATION PROCESS
FOR ALL FUTURE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
I AM A PROUD GRADUATE OF DIESEL
IS LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
GOD GAVE ME THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY FINISH
AND START.
MY.
HIGHER EDUCATION CAREER AND I
UNDERSTAND THIS PERSONALLY IT'S
AS A FIRST GENERATION AMERICAN
IT IS.
THE FIRST STEP.
IN TRYING TO BE THE VERY BEST
THAT WE CAN BE ONE OF MAKE IT AS
EASY AS POSSIBLE FOR STUDENTS
ACTUALLY ACCESS.
HIGHER EDUCATION
WITH ME TO TESTIFY OUR DOCTOR
RYAN GARDNER VICE CHANCELLOR
FROM THE ALLEY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. AND WE THOUGHT NEVADA
AT THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RYAN
CORNER ON THE VICE CHANCELLOR
FOR EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS FOR THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. AND WE ARE SPONSORING.
THIS BILL AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS ALLOW
OUR COLLEGES ARE OUR COLLEGE
SYSTEM TO REVISE THE CCC APPLY
APPLICATION TO INCLUDE DATA
THAT?
IS ONLY THE DATA THAT IS
REQUIRED IN ORDER FOR STUDENTS
TO ATTEND THE COLLEGE AND TO
COLLECT OTHER DATA. AFTER THE
STUDENT HAS ALREADY MATRICULATED
THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
CURRENT PROCEDURES AND
REGULATIONS LED TO A LENGTHY
APPLICATION.
WHICH TAKES OVER AN HOUR TO
COMPLETE IN LEADS TO FIVE
PERCENT OF OUR POTENTIAL
STUDENTS ABANDONING THE PROCESS.
THIS REPRESENTS NEARLY QUARTER
MILLION STUDENTS ABANDONING OVER
THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
A QUARTER MILLION STUDENTS.
THE PROBLEM IS ESPECIALLY
IMPACTFUL IN OUR REGION.
BECAUSE EIGHT OUT OF TEN OF THE
COLLEGES WITH THE HIGHEST
ABANDONMENT RATE RESIDE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
SEVEN OF THEM ARE COLLEGES.
THESE COLLEGES RANGE WITH AN
ABANDONMENT RATE FROM SEVEN
PERCENT TO ELEVEN PERCENT.
THIS THIS ISSUE RAISES QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT.
THE APPLICATION PROCESS IS
IMPACTING.
CERTAIN POPULATIONS FROM BEING
ABLE TO ATTEND COLLEGE.
WHAT WE ESTIMATE IS THAT WERE
IMPACTED IN THE TUNE OF OVER TEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS EACH YEAR JUST
FOR OUR DISTRICT?
ELLIE CCD SUPPORTS THE
COLLECTION OF NEEDED STUDENT
DATA I'M A RESEARCHER BY TRADE
AND I I LOVE HAVING ACCESS TO
THIS DATA.
BUT WE FEEL THAT IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT TO MATRICULATE
STUDENTS INTO THE SYSTEM THAN IT
IS TO COLLECT CERTAIN DATA
ELEMENTS.
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO TRYING
TO FIND WAYS WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO COLLECT
THOSE DATA ELEMENTS. AT A LATER
TIME AFTER THE STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY IN
ROME THE CLASSES THAT THEY NEED.
STUDENTS IN OUR SYSTEM OR VERY A
MAJORITY ARE FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS MORE THAN FORTY
THOUSAND IN OUR SYSTEM HAVE NOT
COMPLETED A HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE.
NON CREDIT PROGRAMS AND ROLE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS EACH YEAR.
WITH MORE THAN EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND ENROLLMENTS IN ESL.
AND YET ALL THE STUDENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT THE SAME
APPLICATION WITH THE SAME
QUESTIONS.
WE STRONGLY ENDORSE THIS AND WE
HOPE TO HAVE HERE AYE VOTES
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN HE NOT
AND.
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HEROD
COMMITTEE ON MY NAME IS A SAD
AND I'M WITH ME COLLEGE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA. AYE THE LEAGUE IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
BILL.
THAT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT A
COLLEGE APPLICATION REPRESENTS
THE BEGINNING OF AN EDUCATIONAL
JOURNEY.
AND RIGHT NOW THAT JOURNEY IS A
SIN HAS
TOO MANY BARRIERS THAT ARE IN
MANY WAYS ARTIFICIAL AND ONES
THAT WE'VE CREATED OURSELVES.
AB THIRTY ONE A ONE WOULD
TRIGGER A MUCH NEEDED REVIEW OF.
CCC APPLY ENSURE THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS INTUITIVE AND IT'S
KEEPING UP WITH THE WAY THAT I.
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS APPLICATIONS
TO ENSURE THAT ITS MOBILE
FRIENDLY THAT IT'S EASY. AND WE
ALSO WERE COLLECTING DATA THAT
IS IMPORTANT AND ACTUALLY
NECESSARY TO MATRICULATE
STUDENTS NOT JUST DATA THAT WE
NEED FOR RESEARCH PURPOSES I CAN
COLLECT AT A DATE AT A LATER
DATE.
THE CURRENT APPLICATION TAKES
OVER AN HOUR.
AND AND AS I MENTIONED INCLUDES
QUESTIONS THAT COULD BE ARE
COLLECTED LATER.
AB THIRTY ONE OH ONE WOULD
ENSURE THAT. EVERY ASPECT OF THE
COMMUTE COLLEGE WORK IS DONE
WITH THE STUDENT CENTERED FOCUS
AND THAT BEGINS WITH AN
APPLICATION THAT ENSURES THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY BEGIN THEIR
JOURNEY THANK YOU.
A KID OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SYNDICATE STAY ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE
FOOTHILL DE ANZA KERN LOS RIOS
PERALTA AND SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NASA MEN ON
BEHALF OF NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
MOUNT SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE AND
THE ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY AND
CONTINUING EDUCATION AND SUPPORT
THINKS.
ALSO WEBSTER BEHALF OF THE COAST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
PRETTY THOMAS WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK BOTH THE
OFTEN THE SPONSORS FOR THE WORK
ON THIS BILL WHILE WE DON'T
OFFICIALLY HAVE A POSITION AT
THIS POINT. CLEARLY CCC APPLIES
OF REPORTS TO A BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
ANY TWEENER WHO'S.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND IT.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IT'S QUIRK SILVA.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
DEFINITELY NOTICE THAT ARE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SUPPORT THIS
BILL NORTH ORANGE COUNTY. AND
OTHER ORANGE COUNTY COLLEGES BUT
I JUST WANTED TO SEE IF YOU
COULD I JUST GIVE US AN EXAMPLE
OF SOME OF THE.
WHERE IT LOOKS LIKE THE
STUDENTS START TO?
DECIDE TO GET OUT OF.
.
COMPLETING THE APPLICATION
PERSONAL QUESTIONS WHAT WOULD BE
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS THAT.
WELL.
THE APPLICATION ITSELF IS JUST
OVER FOURTEEN PAGES LONG.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY APPLY TO GET A
FIREMAN CALIFORNIA MUCH FASTER
WHICH IS ONE PAGE.
AND HERE WE HAVE A THE ACTUAL
APPLET BE APPLICATION AND ALL
THAT ACTUALLY I RYAN SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHERE THE
DROP BUT IT'S IN THE DATA THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS IMPORTANT
AND CRITICAL TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BECAUSE WE DO WANT TO
UNDERSTAND. OF MINORITY GROUPS
AND WHERE THEY STAND IT'S REALLY
SIMPLY. THE.
WHERE IN THE APPLICATIONS SOME
OF THESE QUESTIONS ARE?
YES ACCORDING TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE REVIEW OF
THIS. THE BIGGEST DROP OFFICE IN
THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
QUESTIONS WHICH REPRESENTS
TWENTY THREE PERCENT OF THE
TOTAL DROP OFF OUT OF THAT FIVE
PERCENT ABANDONMENT RATE. AND I
DO APPLAUD THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE FOR TRYING TO MAKE TWEAKS
BECAUSE WHAT THEY DID IS THEY
MOVED THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
TO BE AT.
BUT I THINK THAT THEM
REARRANGING OF THE QUESTIONS IS
A STARTING POINT BUT REALLY
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN ANALYSIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE QUESTIONS
ARE.
STUDENT FOCUSED AND DRIVEN
TOWARD SUCCESS RATHER THAN JUST
THE COLLECTION OF INFORMATION.
BUT I GUESS WHAT MY QUESTION IS
IS WHAT IS THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION THAT THEY SEEM TO
BE.
HAVING AN ISSUE WITH I MEAN I
KNOW. WHAT OPTION DO YOU HAVE
THAT COULD YOU JUST READ A FEW
OF THOSE QUESTIONS I COULD
RETURN QUESTION I WOULDN'T KNOW
WHICH ONES PARTICULARLY WHERE
THE DROP OFF POINTS?
BUT.
WE WE PUT TOGETHER OUR
APPLICATION PAPER WISE FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAD DIFFICULTY
ONLINE. AND THE FIRST SIX
QUESTIONS ARE BASIC INFORMATION
ABOUT DEMOGRAPHICS.
WHERE THAT PEOPLE LIVE AND THEN
IT GOES ON IMMEDIATELY TO
CITIZENSHIP STATUS WHERE
STUDENTS BEGAN WHEN STUDENTS
BEGAN THEIR STAYING CALIFORNIA?
HAVE YOU LIVED IN CALIFORNIA
CONSISTENTLY.
ARE YOU A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE OR
SPOUSE OF A DEPENDENT OF A FULL
TIME EMPLOYEE OF ANY OF THE
FOLLOWING COLLEGES OR
UNIVERSITIES ARE YOU FULL TIME
CREDENTIALED EMPLOYEE OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
ENROLLING IN COLLEGE. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CREDENTIAL RELATED
REQUIREMENTS HAVE YOU BEEN
EMPLOYED AS A SEASONAL
AGRICULTURAL WORKER FOR AT LEAST
THE TOTAL OF TWO MONTHS OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS.
OKAY I I JUST A THREE I WASN'T
REALLY TRYING TO GET THERE BUT
NOW THAT I'M HERE IN THESE
QUESTIONS I CAN SEE WHY. A.
I MEAN I DID GO TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MANY MANY YEARS AGO AND
THIRTY YEARS AGO IF YOU.
BUT YEAH THAT IS A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND AND AGAIN GET
I'M MOVING FORWARD AND IF YOU
NEED THAT THERE'S OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WEBER PS AYE I APPRECIATE
THAT AND.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT I DID AT PROBLEM
WAS I'D BEEN AT THE INSTITUTION
TOO LONG I WOULD IMAGINE BECAUSE
I DON'T FIND SPENDING AN HOUR
FOR AN APPLICATION EXCESSIVE.
I DON'T FIND THIS DIFFICULT TO
DO IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN GOING
TO COLLEGE FISH WHEN YOU WANNA
PICK EXAMPLE TWO TO THREE HOURS
LONG.
AYE AYE I THINK MAYBE THE RANGE
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS COULD BE
DIFFERENTLY BUT I COULD AS YOU
READ THAT BECAUSE I'VE BEEN ON
SEVERAL ADMISSIONS COMMITTEES.
I UNDERSTAND WHITE ONE THOSE
QUESTIONS WILL ASK
BECAUSE EACH ONE OF PUT YOU IN A
DIFFERENT CATEGORY FOR SUPPORT.
AND ONE OF THINGS I WOULD HATE
FOR US TO DO IS TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE SHE.
SCRUBBING EVERYTHING SO MUCH
THAT WE DON'T GET ENOUGH
INFORMATION OF WHAT WE NEED TO
HELP. YOUNG PEOPLE YOU KNOW THE
FACT THAT IF YOU'VE DONE SOME
WORK IN FARMWORKERS AT CERTAIN
BENEFITS TO TO GET AS A RESULT
OF THAT. ABOUT FINANCIAL SYSTEMS
AS WELL AS OTHER KINDS OF THINGS
THAT ARE THERE. WE SOMETIMES
SCRUB ALL THE INFORMATION SO WE
DON'T KNOW FOR MEETING THE NEEDS
OF DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATIONS
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHO THEY
ARE. OF BECAUSE WE CAN'T ASK
PEOPLE OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR
ETHNICITY OR FIRST GENERATION
AND THE SCHOLARSHIPS AND THINGS
THAT COME WITH THAT IN SUPPORT.
SO I THINK WE SHOULD BE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT IT I THINK OF.
HOPEFULLY THOSE WHO WANT TO LOOK
AT IT WILL LOOK AT IT AND BEGIN
TO SAY OKAY THIS IS.
YOU KNOW THIS MAY BE IS NOT
STATED AS FREELY AS WE'D LIKE TO
HAVE IT STATED. BUT YOU KNOW BUT
NOBODY GETS THE INFORMATION THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE.
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES IT IF YOU'RE
A FIRST GENERATION STUDENT OF
CERTAIN BENEFITS IF YOUR PARENTS
ARE ALUMNI OF THAT INSTITUTION
THEIR BENEFITS COME WITH THAT.
SO I YOU KNOW I.
YOU KNOW I I THINK.
IT ANY ANY SORT OF QUESTIONS CAN
BE DIFFICULT THE QUESTION
BECOMES WELL NOT THE INFORMATION
IS GOING TO BE USED FOR PURPOSES
OF PROVIDING SUPPORT TO
STUDENTS.
RATHER EXCLUDING STUDENTS SHOULD
NOT BE.
WHETHER QUESTIONS ARE PUT MAYBE
YOU KNOW COULD BE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT OFFICE A CHECK BOX
VERSUS SOME HAVING TO WRITE A
LOT OF STUFF THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS BUT. YOU KNOW I
SYMPATHIZE EMPATHIZE A LITTLE
BIT WHICH STUDENTS BECAUSE I
KNOW STUDENTS WHO ARE APPLYING
TEN TWELVE DIFFERENT SCHOOLS.
AND A SPIN ALL NIGHT AND DAYS
FILLING UP THESE APPLICATIONS
BECAUSE OF THAT IMPORTANT O I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD IDEA TO
LOOK AT THE APPLICATION. ALL
THAT'S THERE I THINK I HAVE BEEN
SEEING SOME OF THESE THINGS OVER
THE YEARS APPLICATIONS OF KIND
OF GROWN BECAUSE OF THE. THE
RESOURCES THAT COME WITH CERTAIN
QUESTIONS AND AND IN THE
APPLICATION WHERE ONCE IT WAS
VERY FIRST SIMPLE BUT AS YOU
BEGIN TO TALK ABOUT MEETING
STUDENT POPULATIONS OF STUDENT
NEEDS AND. ALL KINDS OF THINGS
AS WELL AS PRE PLANNING FOR.
WHAT KIND OF PROGRAM YOU WANT A
NEED IF YOU GET STUDENTS WITH
CERTAIN NEEDS TO THAT HAVE TO
PRE PLANNED SOME OF THAT SO? I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY AND
HOPE THAT.
THAT AS WE LOOK AT IT A IT'S A
IT'S A REALLY A MATTER OF TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW AN APPLICATION
CAN HAVE AS YOU POINT OUT THE
CENTRAL INFORMATION PEOPLE NEED
TO HAVE.
BUT NOT NECESSARILY GETTING TO
A POINT WE HAVE SUCH AS BEEN
APPLICATION THAT IT THAT
EVERYBODY LOOKS THE SAME.
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY'S APPLIED WE
GOT ALL WE KNOW IS THAT WE HAVE
OF FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS COME A
WILL MOST A MALE FEMALE OR
WHATEVER. WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER
OUR LGBT COMMUNITY NEEDS TO BE
ALL SUPPORTED MORE BECAUSE NOW
WE GOT STUDENTS AT IT THIS WAY
AND OFTEN EVEN VETERAN STATUS IT
ON CAMPUS WILL DETERMINE WHETHER
THAT. THEIR VETERAN SERVICES.
IT IN ANY GREAT NUMBERS SO.
THAT.
THESE KIND OF QUESTIONS ARE ARE
IMPORTANT AND I THINK MAYBE IT
YOU SAY AFTER THEY'VE BEEN ROLE
THEY COULD BE IT BENEFICIAL. BUT
OFTENTIMES THE PRE PLANNING FOR
WHO'S COMING IS ALSO IMPORTANT
OF BECAUSE IF YOU GET STUDENTS
WHO HAVE CERTAIN NEEDS. LASTING
WANT DO IS F. I'M AS NEEDS OUT
IN IN WEEK FIVE OF THE SCHOOL
WHEN WITH WE FOUND AND WEEK ONE
YOU MAY PUT TOGETHER DIFFERENT
KIND OF. OF THE STUDY GROUPS OR
OR RESOURCE IS A WHATEVER TO
HELP STUDENTS TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
SO I WOULD HOPE THAT IN IN THE
SCRUBBING OF THE APPLICATIONS IN
THE ASSESSMENT WE WOULD GET TO
THE THINGS THAT I REALLY CENTRAL
BUT NOT ENOUGH SO HE THOUGHT THE
BABY WITH THE BATHWATER BECAUSE
WE MAY BE ELIMINATING. THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME SERVICES
THAT STUDENTS WOULD WOULD GET AS
A RESULT OF THE DATA. AND
APPLICATIONS THEMSELVES ALWAYS
DIFFICULT I HATE FILLING THEM
OUT BUT.
SO THOSE THINGS YOU HAVE TO DO
BUT I APPRECIATE BRING IT TO OUR
ATTENTION AND THE I HOPE THE
PROCESS THAT THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE
WILL BE LOOKING AT.
IT'LL EN I ALWAYS LOVE SITTING
BY HER TOCHTER WEBER SHE ALWAYS
HAS SO MUCH INSIGHT WHAT THE
DATA BUT ON THIS I THINK IT'S.
IN THE CLIMATE WE ARE IN A WHEN
IT COMES TO APPLICATIONS WHETHER
THEY BE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE UP
FILLING OUT UP FAST OF FORUMS
ALL OF THESE OTHER TYPES OF
FORUMS. I THINK THERE IS SOME
FEAR RELATED TO AND SO A FEW OF
THOSE QUESTIONS THAT YOU KNOW
YOU STARTLE YOU KNOW IF THEY
WORKED IN AGRICULTURE I MEAN.
THAT DOES SEEM LIKE IT'S LEANING
TOWARDS A CERTAIN TYPE OF A.
BIAS OR MAYBE IT ISN'T BABY IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO. USE THE
INFORMATION TO GET THEM EXTRA
SUPPORT BUT I GUESS THE NEXT
QUESTION WOULD BE IS WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO DO WITH THE
INFORMATION AND WHAT DO YOU DO
WITH THAT INFORMATION.
AT THE.
THANK YOU WANT TO RESPOND.
I THINK WE HAD YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THAT I THINK I THINK YOU
MAKE EXCELLENT POINTS AND.
WE THINK THE INTENT OF COLLEGES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS NOT TO
LOSE THIS IMPORTANT DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION THAT CAN HELP US
REALLY SHAPE STUDENT SERVICES.
BUT IT'S REALLY ENSURING THAT.
WE INSIST THAT STUDENTS DO
CONTINUE TO APPLY AND THEN DO
YOU CONSIDER IT.
AND A THOROUGH OVER AND
THOUGHTFUL REVIEW THAT MAYBE HAS
STUDENTS THAT LOOKED THROUGH IT
AND FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW WHERE.
QUESTIONS ARE NOT CRAFTED IN A
WAY THAT REALLY MAKES SENSE TO
THEM I THINK IT'S JUST TIME TO
LOOK AT THAT ON. AND AND AND
ALSO TO TO REVIEW THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S INCORPORATED AND THOSE
THOSE ARE THOUGHTFUL APPROACHES
THAT I THINK WE OWE TO ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS.
PIC MS CUTTY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
VERY THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS THAT I
ALSO VOWED TO SHARE IN TERMS OF
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD FOR
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE WORKABLE
FOR STUDENTS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
SO LOOK.
SO MOVED BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND
BY MISS QUICKSILVER WHEN I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IN THE BILL
FORWARD AND.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT ANY EFFORT TO
SIMPLIFY THE.
THE PROCESS FOR FOR STUDENTS
SO.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY BECAUSE OF A.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER
ARAMBULA BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ
IRWIN.
KILEY
LEVINE. LEVINE AYE LOW. LOW AYE
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
IT'S WHEN YOUR BILL WILL BE ON
CALL.
ZERO.
THE BILL IS ON CALL.
ALRIGHT NEXT ITEM TWELVE MS
BURKE.
A. B. THIRTY.
ZERO EIGHT.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
SHORTER THAN THE REST OF THEM.
YOU MAYBE GET STILL GET THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
AB THREE ZERO ZERO EIGHT
PROVIDES GREATER CONSISTENCY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR STUDENTS WHO
ARE DEPENDENTS OF E. TWO VISA
HOLDERS. OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND IMMIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA SELF EMPLOYED ALMOST
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE EMPLOYED AT
FIRMS OWNED BY IMMIGRANTS.
THIRTY PERCENT OF OUR TRAINERS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE IMMIGRANTS.
E. TWO VISA HOLDERS ARE TAX JUST
AS ANY OTHER CALIFORNIAN AND THE
REV YOU KNOW FROM THEIR TAXES
GOES TOWARDS FUNDING CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS A PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THEIR INVESTMENT SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND FOSTER
THE CREATION OF MORE JOBS WHILE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE STATE'S
BASE.
DESPITE THESE CONTRIBUTIONS
DEPENDENCE OF E. TO BE SO
HOLDERS LOSE THEIR EXEMPTION
FROM OUT OF STATE RESIDENCY
TUITION RATES UPON TURNING
TWENTY ONE. AS THEY ARE NO
LONGER ELIGIBLE TO BE CLAIMED AS
DEPENDENTS AND MUST APPLY FOR
DIFFERENT VISA STATUS.
AB THREE ZERO ZERO EIGHT MIMICS
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
CURRENTLY IN LAW FOR EXEMPTIONS
FOR OUT OF STATE RESIDENTS
EXEMPTIONS AND APPLY THEM TO
DEPENDENCE AB TWO VISA HOLDERS.
AB TWO THREE ZEROES RAY REMOTES
REMOVES AN OBSTACLE FOR STUDENTS
WERE DEPENDS OF E. TWO VISA
HOLDERS AND ALONE LONGER
ELIGIBLE TO BE CLAIMED AS
DEPENDENTS AFTER THEY TURN
TWENTY ONE.
AS THEY COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION WITH ME I HAVE FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MANY JTS ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN JOSE EVERGREEN
COMMUNE COLLEGE DISTRICT TO
SPEED AND SUPPORT THE PILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN JOSE EVERGREEN
COMMITTEE KALLIS'S TRICK.
WE HAVE A TWO CAMPUSES IN NOTE
IN SAN JOSE WERE RIGHT THE HEART
OF SILICON VALLEY.
I WE SERVE OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW OUR SILICON
VALLEY IS REALLY KNOWN FOR.
ISN'T PARTNERSHIP.
THIS PERSON THE TECH INDUSTRY.
PA ONE THING THAT'S REALLY A
PHENOMENA FOR US THOUGH IS THAT
IT'S ALSO VERY DIVERSE WE HAVE
MANY IMMIGRANTS FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
WE HAVE A GROWING LATINO
POPULATION CENTRAL AMERICA FROM
THE VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY.
FROM.
.
THE INDIAN COMMUNITY OR YOU CAN
JUST LOOK AT DIFFERENT PARKS AND
SILICON VALLEY.
AND WHEN WHEN THAT THE E. TO OF
VISA HOLDERS COME TO.
TO AMERICA.
IT'S TOO IF IF IT'S BECAUSE OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THEY THEY MAKE AN INVESTMENT IN
OUR IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
TO START SMALL BUSINESS.
AND IT'S VERY OF POINT A
CONTENTIOUS PART THEIR
DEPENDENTS.
AND SO I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE A CAN. OF
TREAT THESE STUDENTS YES BECAUSE
I TURNED TWENTY ONE AND NOT
CHARGING THE HIGHER OUT COST FOR
TUITION.
SO THIS BILL WILL CREATE THAT
EXEMPTION FOR THEM PER NON
RESTORATION. WE THINK IT'S A
RIGHT THING TO DO. AND OUR OTHER
TWO THIS IS APPLICABLE TO
EVERYBODY HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I MY NAME IS RUTH READ.
I MOVED OVER HERE FROM SCOTLAND
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER WITH MY
PARENTS.
AND.
I AM CURRENTLY AN F. ONE
SHOULDN'T FARMER <c.green>
TO</c>
DEPENDENT ON IT WOULD OF I HAD
TO GO OUT OF STATE FOR A COLLEGE
IN IT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED ME TO
STAY IN. CALIFORNIA WITH MY
FAMILY HAD THIS BEEN IN PLACE A
COUPLE YEARS AGO UNFORTUNATELY
IS TOO LATE BERMAN VERY VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF IT NOW.
FOR THE DID HE TO DEPENDENCE.
.
WHO COULD BENEFIT RIGHT NOW?
THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ELAINE READ SPEAKING EM ON
BEHALF OF THEM OTHER TO BUSINESS
OWNERS LIKE MYSELF.
AMY HUMANISM WE HAVE THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES ON AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY TWEENER.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SORRY I'M I'M JUST A I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE VISA AND THE
INCENTIVE OF THAT THAT.
THE.
THE THE FAMILY MEMBER WHETHER IT
BE THE PARENT A ONE THEM THEY'RE
INVESTING HERE THAT THEY GET.
BUT WHEN THEY'RE TWENTY ONE IT
SAYS.
THAT THEY NEED TO HAVE GONE TO
SCHOOL TIME THREE YEARS OF HIGH
SCHOOL OR AT LEAST THREE YEARS
ATTENDANCE AND GRADUATION.
SO.
I'M I'M JUST CONFUSED BECAUSE
TYPICALLY IF SOMEBODY'S COMING
OVER AND MAKING UP A MAJOR
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA I THINK
IT'S ABOUT A HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS IS THIS NO THAT'S PRETTY
DIFFERENT THOSE ARE A FEW
DIFFERENT THAT'S IN EITHER THAT
THAT'S AN E. B. FIVE. THIS IS AN
EP TO SELECT A DIFFERENT ARE
DIFFERENT OKAY FLOOR THINK YES
YEAH BECAUSE THAT'S THEIR GONNA
EXTENDS TO MAKE THEIR DON'T YOU
THINK YOU EVER.
SO WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
SO THE DIFFERENCE IS AN E. B.
FIVE IS A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ARE CONTRA IS CONTRIBUTION TO
BUSINESS WHERE AS AN EP TWO IS
ANY SUBSTANTIAL SO IF THE
BUSINESS STARTS FOR TEN THOUSAND
OR FIFTY THOUSAND ITS WHATEVER
THAT CONTRIBUTION IS A
SUBSTANTIAL CONTRIBUTION TO IT'S
STARTING OR PARTICIPATING. IN A
BUSINESS.
THAT'S NOT THE TWENTY ONE YEAR
OLD THAT'S THEIR FAMILY MEMBER
RIGHT SO IT'S WHAT SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOMEONE WHO'S
ALREADY IN SCHOOL WHO THAT WOULD
LIKE TO COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATION
AND THEY TURN TWENTY ONE WE JUST
WANNA MAKE PARITY FOR THEM THAT
THAT OTHERS HAVE.
OKAY SO THEY DON'T PAY TUITION
BEFORE THE TORRENT WHEN THEY PAY
IN STATE TUITION STATE YES AND
SO WE'RE JUST ASKING THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO PAY IN STATE TUITION
TO FINISH THEIR SCHOOLING.
THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
BUT I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING IN THE BILL FORWARD.
I SUPPORT THE BILL. AS IT
PROVIDES A NEARLY AS ITS
NARROWLY CRAFTED. AND IT WILL
BENEFIT A SMALL GROUP OF
STUDENTS WHO LIKE THE AB FIVE
FORTY STUDENTS.
ATTENDED AND GRADUATED FROM
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS.
SO THE THE MOTION WAS.
BY MR LOW SECOND BY MISTER
LEVINE. OF THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MADAM SECRETARY.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ
IRWIN.
KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW. LOW AYE PATTERSON
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO THE BILL IS ON CALL.
AND WE'LL GO NEXT TO THE ITEM
THREE MISTER THURMAN OF THIS
YEAR.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT WE
SIGNED WITH AB ONE.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY. A BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
EQUITY PART TIME PLAYGROUND
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED FROM CLASSIFIED SERVICE
THIS IS A CLEAN UP BILL FROM
LAST YEAR'S AB SIX SEVENTY WHICH
I INTRODUCED.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT LANGUAGE NOT
INCLUDE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE IT
MERIT BASED SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE RESULT OF THE EXCLUSION
MEANS THAT THOSE WORKERS STILL
DO NOT RECEIVE SICK LEAVE
VACATION. BEREAVEMENT DE LEAVE
AS THE OTHERS THOSE AT OTHER
SCHOOLS DO.
THESE PARTS ARE PLAYGROUND
PLEASE ARE PREDOMINATELY WOMEN
AND ARE TYPICALLY THE LOWEST
WAGE EARNERS AT THE SCHOOL SITE
MISSES AN OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
THEIR EFFORTS. THEY SUPERVISE
STUDENTS DURING BREAKFAST AND
LUNCH PERIODS.
ESCORTING AND MONITORING
STUDENTS DURING PLAYTIME IN
ASSISTING CLASSIFIED AND
CERTIFICATED STAFF WITH STUDENT
RELATED NEEDS.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY CLEANS UP
THE CODE AND ENSURES FAIRNESS AS
WELL AS EQUITY IN RIGHTS
BENEFITS AND PROTECTIONS FOR ALL
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WORKING PART
TIME PLAYGROUND POSITIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOAT AYE WITH ME TODAY IF CENTER
BUT AT ALL WHOSE REPRESENTS.
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
COMPANIES SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU.
MAYBE GET.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS SANDRA BORRERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL LIKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN SAID
THIS IS A CLEAN UP OF A BILL
THAT WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
LAST YEAR. AND DUE TO A DRAFTING
ERROR PART TIME PLAYGROUND
POSITIONS IN COMMITTEE COLLEGES
AND MERIT SCHOOL DISTRICTS WERE
NOT INCLUDED. SO AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY REMEDIES THAT PROBLEM AND
ENSURES THAT PART TIME
PLAYGROUND AIDES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND MERIT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS RECEIVE THE SAME
RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS AS OTHER
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION WE
BELIEVE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL TO PROVIDE THESE EMPLOYEES
PARITY WITH OTHER CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES AND ASKING I'VE THINK
YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
RUSTY HERE IN SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
TRISTEN BROWN OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER IS ON THIS BILL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NINE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
NEED A SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER MOVED BY MISTER
LOS SECOND BY MISTER LEVINE. AYE
MR THERMAL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
AND MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER. ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ IRWIN.
KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO BILL IS ON CALL.
AND WE'LL GO TO YOUR SECOND BILL
ITEM THIRTEEN. A. B. THIRTY
EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HERE TO PRESENT
A B. THIRTY EIGHTY NINE. THIS IS
THE BILL THAT SEEKS TO HELP
YOUNG ADULTS WHO ARE IN FOSTER
CARE TO OBTAIN EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. OF THIS BILL
EXPANDS WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
MANY YEARS AGO AROUND THE CHAFEE
GRANT PROGRAM. ESSENTIALLY THE
BILL WOULD EXTEND THE BENEFITS
OF THE CHAFEE GRANT. UP FOR THE
APPLICANTS TO USE.
IT EXTENDS THE AGE TO AGE
TWENTY EIGHT
I TYPICALLY THOSE WHO'VE BEEN IN
FOSTER CARE.
HAVE HAD LIFE EXPERIENCES THAT
MAY REQUIRE THEM TO APPLY LATER.
AND SO WE DO NOT WANT THEM TO
MISS OUT ON THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENJOY THE BENEFITS OF HAVING A
CHAFEE GRANT. AYE WITH ME TODAY
ARE A I WOULD SAY THE CO AUTHORS
OF THE BILL A YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE SO COMMITTED TO THEIR OWN
AND TO OTHERS EDUCATION. NOT
THAT THEY CRAFTED AN IDEA THAT
WOULD HELP THEIR PEERS UP PLEASE
HELP ME WELCOME JESSE AGUILAR.
CARMEN LOYOLA AND TO SETTLE NAY
ALLAH WHO ARE ALL A PART OF THE
SPONSORS OF ORGANIZATION.
WHICH IS CALLED JOURNEY HOUSE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN I
I'M GONNA ASK THE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TO ADHERE TO WHAT WE SAID AT
THE OUTSET.
TO HEAR TWO WITNESSES SO. TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES SO.
YOU CAN WORK THAT OUT YEARS IT
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT WE
HAVE DIVIDED OUR TIME TO. TRY TO
KEEP WITHIN THE PARAMETERS OF
THAT WE WERE ALLOCATED THREE
MINUTES THREE WITNESSES FOUR
MINUTES IS THAT REALLY WITNESSES
ONE ALRIGHT. KEEP THAT.
IT TOO THAT'S A LIVE MUSIC AND
PERFECT THAT I'M.
GOOD AFTERNOON AYE CHEN MEMBERS.
AS WAS MENTIONED MY NAME IS JEFF
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING JENNY
HOUSE AT THE SPONSORS OF A. B.
THIRTY. A EIGHTY NINE FOR THE
PAST THIRTY FIVE YEARS JOHNNY
HOUSES PROVIDED INDIVIDUALIZED
SUPPORT THE FORMER FUSS YOU'VE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
PRIMARILY WE SERVE FORMER PASTA
YOU TWENTY TWO YEARS OF AGE YOU
ARE AN OLDER SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE COUNTY IN STATE SUPPORT.
AND AT TWENTY TWO.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE SIXTY STUDENTS
IN COLLEGE FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SEE IF USE UC'S TO EVEN
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
TWENTY OF THEM WILL BE
GRADUATING TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
NINETEEN OF THOSE GRADUATES ARE
TWENTY TWO YEARS OF AGE AND
OLDER.
WE ATTRIBUTE THE SUCCESS RATES
TO THE FACT THAT RESOURCES ARE
ALLOCATED TO ME EACH
INDIVIDUAL'S NEED REGARDLESS OF
AGE.
THE TV GRANT. A FEDERAL PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS SHOWN.
I SUCCESS IN INCREASING COURSE
COMPLETION
AND GRADUATION RATE RATES UP FOR
THOSE WHO ACCESS THIS GRANT.
THIS IS DUE TO THE FACT THAT
WHILE IT'S A MODEST GRANT FOR TO
JUST FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
COVER SCHOOL RELATED EXPENSES.
BEYOND TUITION AND FEES SUCH AS
FOOD.
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND
CHILDCARE WHICH SUPPORTS THE
HOSTED IN THEIR ABILITY TO STAY.
IN AND COMPLETE OUR SCHOOL.
BY SPENDING THE AGE LIMIT TO
EACH TWENTY EIGHT ST WOULD ALLOW
OLDER FOSS YOU. TO ALSO BENEFIT
FROM THIS IMPORTANT GRANT.
AFFIRMATIVE FIVE YEARS OF THEIR
EDUCATION.
I'M IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT
WE ARE URGING YOUR AYE VOTE ON
AB THIRTY EIGHT IN MY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CARMEN IOWA AND I
ENTERED THE CALIFORNIA FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AT THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN. AND THAT THEY JUST
SEVENTEEN I BECAME A SINGLE
MOTHER HARDLY OLDER THAN A CHILD
MYSELF. I KNEW MY PURDY HAD TO
BE PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE SO
I STARTED WORKING FULL TIME.
WITH COLLEGE SEEMING A LUXURY I
COULD JUST NOT AFFORD AT THE AGE
OF TWENTY TWO I REALIZE I WANT
MORE FOR MY SON. SO I ENTERED
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
I HEARD FROM MY PEERS ABOUT
CHAFEE WITH PROVIDED SUPPORT
THAT COULD INCLUDE HOUSING AND
CHILD CARE. IT GAVE ME HOPE THAT
IT WAS POSSIBLE TO GO TO COLLEGE
EVEN OF THE SINGLE MOM AND
FORMER FOSTER YOU. AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY FOUR A TRANSFERRED TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA USC.
I ENTERED THE WITH THE AND I NO
LONGER QUALIFY FOR CHAFEE SO
ATTENDING UNIVERSITY THE COST
SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR SEEMED IMPOSSIBLE.
FORTUNATELY I WOULD ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE THE CAL GRANT TO ASSIST
ME WITH TUITION AND FEES I ALSO
RECEIVED. A MERIT SCHOLARSHIP
FROM USC FOR MY HIGH GRADES
THIS AND THE MULTIPLE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO NOT HAVE
AGE RESTRICTIONS HELP MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR ME TO CONTINUE MY
EDUCATION. DESPITE THE LOSS OF
CHAFEE.
MY FOUGHT MANY FOSTER STUDENTS
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
NETWORKS AND RESOURCES FOR THE
COST OF COLLEGE DETER THEM FROM
TRYING OR CONTINUING.
CURRENTLY I AM BOTH AN
UNDERGRADUATE SENIOR AND A FIRST
YEAR GRADUATE STUDENT TAKING
EIGHTEEN UNITS EACH SEMESTER
WORKING TWO JOBS ALL WHILE
TAKING CARE OF MY SON. I'M
OVERLOADING MYSELF BECAUSE I
KNOW I WILL BE LOSING FINANCIAL
SUPPORT SOON AND I DO NOT KNOW
HOW OR IF I WILL BE ABLE TO
FINISH MY EDUCATION. EXTENDING
TAKE ME TO THE AGE OF TWENTY
EIGHT WHAT LEVY AND ENORMOUS
BURDEN FOR STUDENTS LIKE ME
COULD DEPEND ON THESE PROGRAMS
TO FIGHT TO FIND OUR SCHOOL
RELATED EXPENSES I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT. A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY
NINE AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
FOSTER YOU IN PURSUIT OF OUR FOR
EDUCATIONAL POTENTIAL THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IT LOOKS AT ONLY ALLOWED
I'M A FORMER FALL TWO. PERCENT A
MONSTER THAT USC SIMILAR TO
CARMEN AND TO FOSTER CARE AT THE
AGE OF SIXTEEN. I HAVE MY
DAUGHTER AT THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
AND I KNEW I HAD TO GO TO SCHOOL
OF I WANTED TO PROVIDE HER A
BETTER FUTURE I STARTED AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND START
RECEIVING THE CHAFEE GRANT RIGHT
BEFORE I TURNED TWENTY I
TRANSFERRED TO USC AND RECEIVED
THE CHAFEE GOT UNTIL MY SENIOR
YEAR.
ONCE I TURNED TWENTY THREE IT
WAS NO LONGER ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE CHAFEE THE LOSS OF THIS
FLEXIBLE SUPPORT WHILE ALSO
EXUDING TRIES ON HOUSING WITH A
HUGE BLOW TO MY STABILITY. MY
DAUGHTER AND I WERE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS AND IT STARTS TO
GET AND I STRUGGLE TO GET
THROUGH MY LAST YEAR OF SCHOOL
DESPERATE NOT TO BE FORCED TO
DROP OUT.
ONLY THIRTY PERCENT OF ALL TO
THEM RULING BECAUSE FOR SAYS
PAST ONE YEAR COMPARED TO FIFTY
SIX PERCENT OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION.
CRISTINA RESIDUE FOUND THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE MANY ARE LIVING
WITH PARENTS
UNTIL THE AGE OF THIRTY FIVE TO
AVOID POVERTY FOR FOSTER YOU.
THIS TYPE OF FAMILIAL SAFETY NET
JUST DOES NOT EXIST WE ON OUR
OWN STRIVING TO FIND THE WAYS.
TO BE SELF SUFFICIENT EXPLAINING
CHAFEE TO A TWENTY EIGHTH PARTS
CALIFORNIA FOSTERED IN THEIR
PURSUIT OF HIGHER EDUCATION. WE
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB THIRTY
EIGHTY NINE AND ALLOW OLDER
FOSSE YOU TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
FOR SELLING THINGS THE AUTHOR
MY NAME IS DOCTOR MIKE SEGURA
MORE FROM A FOSTER YOUTH WHO
WENT ON TO EARN A PHD.
I CAN ATTEST TO THE EXPERIENCE
THAT WAS PRESENTED TO YOU
ALREADY. AND SHARE THAT.
.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET TO SEE MANY
OTHER FORMER FOSTER EVEN HIGHER
EDUCATION LIKE MYSELF IF NOT FOR
SUPPORT LIKE THIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANGELIQUE WOULD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER IS ON THIS BILL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE.
.
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
MISTER THURMOND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE A THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
LATITUDE ON THE FOUR MINUTE
CLOCK THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
THAT'S THE NEW MATH RECALL THAT
A BIT LA DID WELL.
AYE AYE I COMMEND THE STUDENTS
FROM USC BUT I YOU HAVE IT BUT.
I THINK THEY SAID IT ALL I THINK
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
MAKE A DEEPER INVESTMENT.
AND AND GREAT STUDENTS ARM
YOU'VE HEARD THEIR EXPERIENCES
ARTICULATED AND ON THEIR BEHALF
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTES AND I WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR OF FOR HIS CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO SERVING THE NEEDS
OF CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. AND ISAIAH FORMER
CLASSROOM TEACHER AND IS THE
CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION I
ECHO.
OF THE STUDENTS.
.
STORIES AND I THANK THEM FOR
BEING HERE THIS AFTERNOON AND
SHARING THEIR EXPERIENCES. ALONG
WITH THE THE WITNESS FROM THE
THE AUDIENCE
SO WE HAVE A. MOTION BY MISTER
LOW AND A SECOND BY MISS QUIRK
SILVA. AYE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MADAM SECRETARY OF
YOU'D CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
ARAMBULA
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHáVEZ IRWIN.
KILEY
LEVINE.
LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
I AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO REQUEST
IF I COULD BE A PRINCIPAL AUTHOR
OR A JOINT AUTHORS WOULD BE
HONORED.
QUIRK SILVA I SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
FIVE ZERO THAT BILL IS ON CALL
THANK YOU THINK IF.
WE HAVE ANY AUTHORS.
AND WEBER.
THE.
GOOD.
WELL WE CAN WE CAN DO CONTENT
WHICH IS GOING DOWN THERE.
YOU CONSENT.
SO WE'RE WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO.
CONSENT ITEMS WHILE DR WEBBER
GET SETTLED IN.
CAN WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE CONCERT.
WE NEED SECOND.
SO MOVED BY.
MISTER BLOOM SECOND BY MISTER
PATTERSON ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
A MADAM SECRETARY MICHAEL ROW
PLEASE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER
ARAMBULA BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CHáVEZ IRWIN. KILEY LEVINE LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER
AYE WEBER AYE.
FIVE ZERO CONSENT IS ON CALL AND
WE ARE NOW ON ITEM.
ITEM FIVE.
FINE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR. AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE.
REGARDING SERVICE CONTRACTS FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
I LIKE TO SAY THAT I AGREE TO
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING PLACING THE INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS NAMES WITH THE UNIQUE
IDENTIFIER.
BUT WE WANT TO KEEP BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO KEEP HOWEVER THE UC
PENALTY ASPECT THAT HAS BEEN
REQUESTED FOR AMENDMENT. I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS AND WE'RE WORKING TO REFINE
THE THE LANGUAGE AROUND THIS
PARTICULAR POINT.
I WE WILL WE WILL KEEP THE
COMMITTEES INFORMED AS TO UP
WHEN WE MOVE FORWARD IN WELCOME
THEIR INPUT.
AND THISIS NOT THE FIRST TIME
YOU HEARD THIS ISSUE BEFORE YOU
NO LESS THAN THREE BILLS HAVE
BEEN PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE ON
THE TOPIC OF YOU SEE
OUTSOURCING.
CONTRACTS
WHAT IS DIFFERENT ABOUT THE REAL
BEFORE YOU IS THAT NOW WE HAVE A
STATE AUDIT THAT ECHOES MANY OF
OUR CONCERNS.
MORE THAN A MORE THAN THAT MORE
THAN ABOUT THAT LATER HOWEVER
THIS IS WHAT WE WANT AND WE.
THIS IS WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
TEMPORARY WORKERS.
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO BE AN
IMMIGRANT OR PERSON OF COLOR.
THE ERNIE LOW WAGES WITH FEWER
IF NO BENEFITS
THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO RELY ON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
THE QUESTION ONCE AGAIN BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE IS ONE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONTRACTING PRACTICES ARE
CONDEMNING LOW WAGE EMPLOYEES TO
POVERTY.
AND THE RELIANCE ON TAXPAYER
FUNDED SOCIAL SERVICES.
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT
THERE IS NO WAY OF KNOWING
BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T KEEP TRACK.
SO WE'RE PROVIDING A MECHANISM
FOR TRANSPARENCY.
VENDORS ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT EACH
EMPLOYEE'S PAY AND BENEFITS TO
THE UNIVERSE OF CALIFORNIA
CHANCES OFFICE.
THE JUSTICE OFFICE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO POST THIS
INFORMATION ON A PUBLIC
ACCESSIBLE WEBSITE.
IF THE VENDOR FAILS TO PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION THEY WOULD NOT
BE ELIGIBLE TO CONTRACT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA UP TO FIVE
YEARS.
IF THE UNIVERSE OF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO CONTRACT WOULD
VENDORS WHO ARE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE REQUIREMENT
OF THIS BILL THE LEGISLATIVE
WILL DEDUCT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
DEDUCT THE AMOUNT OF THE
CONTRACT. FROM THEIR BUDGET
ALLOCATION
THIS WILL PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY
REGARDING CONTRACTORS PAY
COMPARED TO UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES
DOING COMPARABLE WORK.
IT WILL PROVIDE CLARITY ABOUT
WHETHER THE UNIVERSITY IS
ENFORCING ITS OWN MINIMAL WAGE
POLICIES AND WHETHER THESE
EMPLOYEES RECEIVE AT ANY HEALTH
OR RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE WILL
ALSO ALLOW THE LAWMAKERS TO GAZE
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THESE
CONTRACTS SHIP COSTS WHO STATE
BY THESE EMPLOYEES HAVING TO
RELY ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS CLAUDIA PREPARA
FROM ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE. AND TAMIRA ARE
GETTING A FORMER WORKER WITH THE
UC CONTRACTOR.
I ALSO HAVE JULIE WHAT WATERS
WITH ISSUE FROM ASK ME FOR
TECHNICAL SINCE.
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CLAUDIA FOR PRADA AND
I'M THE RESEARCH DIRECTOR FOR
ASKED ME THIRTY TO NINETY NINE
THE LARGEST UNION. AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OF
REPRESENTING TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SERVICE IN PATIENT CARE
TECHNICAL WORKERS I THANK.
DOCTOR WEBER FOR HER SPONSORSHIP
OF THIS BILL AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY.
I'M HERE TO REGISTER THE UNION
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY THREE
SIXTY ONE WHICH QUITE SIMPLY
REQUEST AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MAINTAIN A PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE DATABASE OF ITS
SERVICE CONTRACTORS.
THE INTO OF THE LEGISLATION IS
TWOFOLD FIRST PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE A VEHICLE TO MONITOR
UC'S PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING THE
STATE AUDITOR'S CRITICISMS. OF
ITS CONTRACTING OUT PRACTICES
AND SECOND CONFIRMED THE EXTENT
OF UC'S USE OF LOW WAGE
CONTRACTORS.
LAST YEAR THE STATE AUDITOR
FOUND THAT YOU SEE CONTRACTING
OUT RESULTS NOT JUST IN THE
DISPLACEMENT BUT ALSO IN THE
AVOIDANCE OF HIRING YOU SEE
SERVICE WORKERS.
YOU SEE CONTRACTORS ARE PAID UP
TO EIGHT DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS
LESS THAN YOU SEE SERVICE
WORKERS JUNE COMPARABLE WORK.
UC'S OUTSOURCING OF SERVICE WORK
IS NOT JUST TEMPORARY I'M
ADDITIONAL YOU SEE DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY MEASURE SUPPOSE THAT
COST SAVINGS OR EFFICIENCIES
RESULTING FROM THE OUTSOURCING.
AND USE YOUR NEWS CONTRACTS
REPEATEDLY OFTEN WITHOUT HEARING
TO COMPETITIVE BIDDING
REQUIREMENTS.
THE INFORMATION PROVIDED UNDER
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE WOULD
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE AND
OTHER INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS
THE ABILITY TO MONITOR UC'S
PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING. THE
AUDITOR'S CONCERNS THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD BE AFFECTED.
ONLY IF IT FAILS TO PROVIDE THE
CONTRACTOR DATA OR FAILS TO
DECLARE AN UNCOOPERATIVE
CONTRACTOR AN UNQUALIFIED BITTER
FOR FUTURE WORK IN OTHER WORDS.
YOU SEE CAN AVOID CONSEQUENCE BY
TAKING SIMPLE AND REASONABLE
STEPS.
LASTLY THE UNIONS RECENT REPORT
FINDS THAT THE AVERAGE STARTING
PAY FOR LATINO AND BLACK WORKERS
AND AFTER REPRESENTED TITLES IS
AT LEAST TWENTY PERCENT LOWER
THAN WHITE WORKERS.
AND THAT THE NUMBER OF BLACK
WORKERS THAT YOU SEE HAS
DECREASED BY THIRTY SEVEN
PERCENT.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX WHILE
CONTRACTOR SURVEYS SUGGEST
OUTSOURCED CONTRACTORS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE BLACK. THEN YOU SEE
SERVICE WORKERS.
AS A THIRD LARGEST EMPLOYER IN
THE STATE YOU SEE AS A DRIVER
BOTH SOCIAL MOBILITY AND
EQUALITY THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
ITS EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES HAVE
IMPLICATIONS NOT JUST FOR THE
UNIVERSITY BUT FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE.
THEREFORE SHINING A LIGHT ON ITS
CONTRACTING OUT PRACTICES IS A
MATTER OF STATEWIDE CONCERN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY.
MY NAME IS TOM LITTLE GET OUT I
WHAT CA AS A BODY.
AT UCLA FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
MANY OF MY COWORKERS HAD BEEN
WORKING AT UCLA SCENES THE
HOSPITAL. OPENED TEN YEARS AGO
WE WHAT COULD REPLACE HEAVING
PATIENT US AND IS IT FARMING
THESE. ARE THE HOST BATON BLOWS
OUT THE EMERGENCY.
SIDE US WITH US THE MEAN IN
TORRANCE TO THE HOSPITAL.
WHEN I STARTED WORK AT THE BODY
OF THE UCLA I MEET THE MINIMUM
WAGE.
UP UNTIL A LITTLE OVER A YEAR
AGO.
I MADE JUST TEN DOUGHNUTS
AND FIFTY CENT PER HOUR.
WHERE US UCLA WHAT CUTS DOING
THE SAME WORK?
WOULD MAKE.
FROM EIGHTEEN UP TO TWENTY CITY
ON HOWARD'S.
WITH A FULL BENEFIT BUT.
ONLY AFTER TOM OFF MIKE
COWORKERS SPOKE UP
DID WE EVER EVEN RECEIVE THE
FOURTEEN DOLLARS UC MINIMUM.
ALL THE WORKING CONDITIONS ARE
SUBCONTRACTORS EMPLOYEES IN THE
HOSPITAL WITH ALSO DIFFICULT'S
FOR EXAMPLE.
THE AIR QUALITY IS IN THE
PARKING STRUCTURE IS VERY.
POR.
SOMETIMES THE PETITION IN THE
AIR SO BAD THAT IS HARD TO TO
BREEZE AND TO SOME OF OUR
COWORKERS HOP BEING.
FAINTED WIDE WORKING.
DOWNSTAIRS.
THIS WHERE IT WOULD BE.
BACK UP DOWN THE STAIRS AND YET
WE WERE TOLD TO CONTINUE.
OUT OF WHAT CAN.
SUDDENLY
MANY OF MY COWORKERS HAVE
DEVELOPED PUT ASTHMA AND OTHERS
EXPLANATORY PROBLEMS.
SCENES WORKING US QUATTROPORTE
CUTS OF THE UC IN NAME.
SO WHEN WE WE HAD THAT YOU SEE
TODAY WAS TAKING OVER OPERATIONS
OVER THE VIOLATE WE WILL
HOPEFULLY THAT WE WOULD FINALLY
GET A CHANCE AT A BETTER JOB.
AND A DECENT
FUTURE.
FOR ME HAVING A KID DROP AT UCLA
WOULD MEAN.
I COULD FIND NINETY PROVIDE A
SECURE LIFE FOR MY FAMILY MY
WIFE AND MY SON.
EXECUTE DROP AT UCLA WOULD MEAN
THAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO RETIRE
ONE DAY.
IT WOULD MEAN THAT WE WOULD BE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE SIDE OF THE
SET WE PROVIDE.
FOR THE PATIENT BECAUSE OF THE
UCLA MEDICAL CENTER. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY UTILITY HARD TO
DECIDE TWO DATES MOST OF US GO
OUT.
WITHOUT GIVING IT CREDIT FOR OUR
PRICELESS CONTRIBUTIONS.
THEY WANT TO REPLACE US WITH A
STUDENT WHAT CUT WHAT COULD WHAT
KIND OR CUTS.
PULL THE ECONOMY CONTINUAL TO
PAY LESS WITH NO BENEFITS.
YOU SAID THERE WAS HAPPY TO HAVE
US
TO DO THE WORK. WHEN THEY COULD
PAY US THE MINIMUM WAGE BUT.
NOW.
THEY HAVE TO GIVE US A DECENT
JOB THEY SAY THEY DO NOT NEED US
ANYMORE.
I LOVE MY JOB AT UCLA AND I TOOK
PRIDE IN PROVIDING EXCELLENT
SERVICE TO THE PATIENTS AND
THEIR. FAMILIES
MY COWORKERS AND I SORT OF IT
THE PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
FOR YEARS AND ALL OF US DESERVED
TO STAY.
YOU SEE AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR.
SHEDDING MY QUOTA.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION OVER
HERE STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME'S BRIAN ASORIO
AGAIN I'M A BOARD MEMBER ON THE
U. CSA. PRESSED LA I SENSE ARE
VERY WITH ASK ME THREE TWO NINE
NINE. AND I LIKE TO READ A
LETTER THAT WE DRAFTED.
IT'S GOING TO.
AS WITH YOUR STATEMENT ALREADY.
BOB THAT'S THE POLICY THANK YOU
ARE ACTS.
THE NAME IS JEN SLOSS PERGAMON
UNDERGRADUATE AT UC BERKELEY AND
I AM ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANY CLEANERS ON THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERS JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL AT
THIS TIME.
HOWEVER WE DO WANT TO RISE TODAY
TO SHARE OUR CONCERNS WITH THE
MEASURE.
I GUESS I JUST PUT IT SIMPLY WE
DO NOT BELIEVE WILL BE ABLE TO
COMPLY WITH THIS BILL WITH
RESPECT TO THE WAGE AND.
INFORMATION DATA THIS REQUEST
OF OUR VENDORS WE'VE LEARNED
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS AS
MISSILE AND WEBER WAS THAT THE
TESTING TO WITH THE.
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE LARA
BILLS THAT IS THEY THEY WERE NOT
TO BE ABLE TO GET OURSELVES UP
AVAILABLE TO OUR VENDORS AYE IN
MANY CASES VIEW THAT INFORMATION
IS PROPRIETARY. AND.
WOULD NOT BELIEVABLE SKIN
SECURE THAT LETS THAT
INFORMATION WHICH IN TURN WILL
FIND OURSELVES WILL FIND
OURSELVES OUT OF COMPLIANCE THE
BILL WITH RESPECT TO. OUR VENDOR
SUPPLYING IT AND POTENTIAL
IMPACTS TO THE UNIVERSITY BASED
BUDGET SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WE WE FINALLY WE
BELIEVE THIS IS ESSENTIALLY A.
DE FACTO WAY TO LIMIT THE VERSES
ABILITY TO OUR CONTRACT OUT
EFFECTIVELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE BILL.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
AFTER LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESEARCH AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS SAY IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
AND TO THE TESTIMONY BECAUSE I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY FOR THE
VALUES THAT WE AS A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION HAVE.
IN SERVING A STUDENTS AND THE
ECOSYSTEM AND SO WE NEED TO LEAD
WITH THAT BUT HAVING SAID THAT I
DID. HAVE A QUESTION AND
APOLOGIES IF I MISSED IT.
BUT THE A A NOTED ANALYSIS WITH
RESPECT TO SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. OF FOR EXAMPLE
WITH THE.
OF FALSIFICATION PERHAPS ISSUE
THE CONTRACTOR FAILED TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION IS REQUIRED I DIDN'T
KNOW IF THE AUTHOR WAS STILL
OPENS UP TO THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AS LISTED ANALYSIS.
I THINK.
YEAH WE WERE OPEN TO IT YEAH
WERE STILL LOOKING AT THAT YEAH
BUT SO IT MIGHT UNDERSTAND THAT.
THE AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AS
PRESENTED.
THAT NO NOT AT THEIR PRESENT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO WORK ON THAT
BECAUSE ONE OF THE REALITIES IS
IS THAT.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
STATE. IS SUCH AS A IS OF SUCH
THAT THE ONLY LEVERAGE YOU HAVE
TO GET COMPLIANCE.
IF THE MONEY.
THAT THAT'S THE ONLY LEVERAGE WE
HAVE EVERYTHING YOU KNOW EVEN
BILLS THAT WE RIGHT ALL
SUGGESTIONS.
WE SUGGEST THIS WITH ITS IT
CURRICULUM OF WHETHER IT'S
POLICY OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE IF
IT'S ALL SUGGESTIONS SO THE ONLY
THE ONLY ABILITY WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT. OUR WISHES ARE KNOWN
AS WE KNOW IS REALLY THROUGH THE
BUDGET WE DO THAT IN TERMS OF.
STUDENT INVOLVEMENT.
THAT SELL YOU KNOW WE WANT
INCREASED INVOLVEMENT ONLY WAY
WE CAN DO IT IS BY.
BUT GETTING AN AGREEMENT TO THE
BUDGET TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO OF
WE'RE LOOKING MORE INTO TO SEE
HOW WE CAN REFINE IT BUT UP. WE
WANT ACCOUNTABILITY WE WANT TO
CA AND THE ONLY WAY TO GET COUNT
ABILITY BASICALLY IS TO. SAY
THAT IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
COMPLY WHAT SHOULD WE BE
CONTRACTING OUT.
SO.
SO CAN YOU HELP ME OF BEST
UNDERSTAND THEN BECAUSE I AYE
BUT I'M HEARING IS THAT YOU
AGREE WITH.
THE ANALYSIS WITH EFFECTIVE IT
THAT YOU AMENDMENTS.
MOVING FORWARD BUT PROCESS WISE
STATE YOU WAS ON IT I THINK WE
MIGHT MENTION THAT WE AGREED
WITH ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
NOT THAT THEIR LIVES THE WHAT WE
ARE.
WHAT IT AYE AYE SAID THE
BEGINNING?
WHERE MY?
THAT WE AGREED WITH ONE OF
THOSE WHICH IS NOT PUTTING UP
PEOPLE'S NAMES OF THAT'S THERE
BUT WE DID NOT AGREE TO THAT. TO
TAKE AWAY THE PENALTY.
FOR NON COMPLIANCE.
HEY I THINK ARE.
.
I DIDN'T MISS RIVER MAYBE TO
SOME CLARIFICATION OF AYE MY TWO
BEST UNDERSTAND.
THE ALL THE OTHERS DESIRE.
WITH RESPECT TO THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN NOTED ANALYSIS ON
A PAGE FOR A PEACEFUL.
SO IT.
ON PAGE FOUR.
WE KNOW IT'S AN UNDER
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IT IT IT IT.
BUT NOT WITH THE AUTHOR WITH
INSTEAD OF TO THE CHAIR. THAT TO
BEST UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS
EXACTLY.
THE BILL IS BEING PRESENTED AS
IS WITHOUT ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S MANDATE IS THAT IS
THAT WHAT INVEST IS THAT WHAT I
UNDERSTOOD IT TO AMENDMENTS YEAH
OKAY.
YES SO THAT OTHER AUTHOR IS
CREDITED ACCEPTING ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS BUT NOT THAT THE
SECOND.
RIGHT AS LISTED NUMBER AS LISTED
NUMBER TWO IS THAT RIGHT SO YOU.
THOSE ARE YOU'RE ACCEPTING.
AMENDMENT NUMBER ONE IT LISTED
ON PAGE FOUR. AND THEN.
ACRYLIC IS CURRENTLY TO THE
CLIMBING ON US ON PAGE FIVE THE
SECOND MEMBERS IS THAT ACCURATE
RIGHT THERE.
JUST.
DOCTOR WEBER.
TRY TO BE BETTER THAN WHAT THAT
WANTED TO LISTEN AND WALDRON
BANK THAT THE SAME ONES LISTA.
AMENDMENT WIND.
SECTION NINE TWO OH SIX TWO.
TO READ.
UNIQUE INDIVIDUAL IDENTIFIER.
YES.
AND WE'VE AGREED TO THAT.
WE'VE AGREED TO THAT.
AND NUMBER TO AMEND SECTION NINE
TWO. ZERO SIX TWO.
THE UNIVERSITY SHALL SUBSTITUTE
A UNIQUE IDENTIFIER IN PLACE OF
THAT INDIVIDUAL NAME MOVEMENT.
ALSO BEEN AGREED TO IT WE'VE
AGREED ON THOSE TO YES BRIGHTON.
YES WE'VE AGREED TO THOSE TWO
THAT DEAL WITH THE UNIQUE
IDENTIFIER AND THE NAMES.
BUT BUT GOT THEM FORCE THAT
LANGUAGE THAT THE.
NOT OKAY.
LET.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DR WEBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YES I'D I WANT TO THANK THOSE
WHO ARE HERE TODAY AND FOR THOSE
WHO HAD QUESTIONS A UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S WHO KNOWS ONE OF
OUR LARGEST EMPLOYEES IN THE
STATE.
AND WHAT THEY DO WILL HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT UPON US STATEWIDE
EMPLOYMENT AS WELL AS THE ISSUE
POVERTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
WORKING TO ALLEVIATE POLICY
PROPERTY FROM THE NUMBER OF WITH
A NUMBER OF MEASURES INCLUDING
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
BRAKES FOR WORKING FAMILIES. AND
A FIFTEEN DOLLAR MINIMUM WAGE.
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT WHEN THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA COMES AS
THE ALLOCATIONS FOR THESE
CONTRACTS THAT THEY TOO ARE ARE
OF THAT WE'RE VOTING NOT TO
REVERSE OUR EFFORTS BUT TO
UPLIFT THE EFFORTS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WITH REGARD TO THE
ECONOMY AND THAT THEY TOUR ARE
BUYING INTO THE FLOSS MOVIE
HAPPY ABOUT REDUCING POVERTY AND
PAYING AT LEAST AT A MINIMUM
WAGE OF FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR.
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT WHETHER WE
ARE PAYING TO KEEP THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS IN POVERTY AND LINE UP
ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE WILL GIVE US THE
TRANSPARENCY WE NEED TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND. HOW THESE
OUTSOURCING CONTRACTS AFFECT
CALIFORNIA WORKERS HOW ALSO FIND
IT INCREDIBLE AND SOMEWHAT
UNBELIEVABLE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA HAS NO MECHANISM FOR
MAINTAINING DATA AND INFORMATION
I MEAN THEY ARE THE? THE PREMIER
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS OF THE OF
THE NATION AND THE WORLD AND
IT'S FIND I FIND IT
INCONCEIVABLE THAT THEY WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO COLLECT DATA FROM
THEIR VENDORS.
AND KNOWING WHAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOES HAVE DONE AND AND
COMPLIANCE WITH A CERTAIN KINDS
OF OF RULES AND REGULATIONS EVEN
SMALL CITIES.
OTHER PLACES ARE ABLE TO WHEN
THEY DEAL WITH EEOC AND OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS ARE ABLE TO
COLLECT DATA CONCERNING THEIR
CONTRACTORS VENDORS AND THE
COMPOSITION OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
SO I AYE BELIEVING IN THE IN THE
WHAT I WOULD CONSULT CONSIDERED
TO BE ALMOST THE LIMITLESS POWER
OF THE RESEARCH AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. I
BELIEVE THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE US WITH THE DATA WE NEED
FROM THEIR VENDORS TO ENGAGE IN
THE CONTRACTS OF THEIR EYES
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I'D VOTE
FOR THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
I I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
SO MOVED BY MISTER SANTIAGO
SECOND BY MISS QUIRK SILVA.
AND.
.
WE TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES.
SITTING IN AN SUB TO.
COMMITTEE.
A TODAY LOOKING AT THE.
.
BUDGET OF YOU SEE.
I I WILL REITERATE AND.
THAT GO.
DOCTOR WEBER'S COMMENTS THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO COST SAVINGS.
AS WE LOOK AT THE BUDGET.
AND AS WE LOOK AT UC.
I WOULD JUST REPEATAGAIN I
THINK WHAT I SAID WHEN THESE
BILLS FIRST CAME THROUGH AS. A
MISTER SENATOR LARA'S BILL THAT
YOU SEE CANNOT.
.
WE'RE NOT GONNA SEE MUCH SAVINGS
AND.
IN THE UC BUDGET.
IF WE LOOK AT THAT SAVINGS AT
THE BOTTOM.
THAT IT WOULD TAKE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNTS AND MAYBE THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE SEEING.
WHEN WE SEE OUTSOURCING OF JOBS.
.
UNDERCUTTING OF WORKERS
A AND AND OUTSOURCING
SO I I WOULD AGAIN CALLING YOU
SEE TO LOOK AT THAT.
.
THEIR POLICIES.
SO AYE THANK DOCTOR WEBER FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD.
BUT I DO HAVE.
SOME CURRENT CONCERNS AZZA
POINTED OUT BY.
MR LOW THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE'S HANDS
BEING TIED. A IN THE IN THE
FUTURE BUDGET YEARS BASED ON A
INFORMATION FROM A THIRD PARTY.
THAT MAY NOT HAVE BEEN PROVIDED.
I UNDERSTAND AND I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER PLAN TO WORK ON
THE LATTER LANGUAGE MOVING
FORWARD. AND I ASK YOU TO
CONTINUE TO WORK. WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE FUTURE
LANGUAGE.
MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WITH
THAT I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND.
MADAM SECRETARY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
CHAVEZ.
BLOOM I.
IRWIN.
KILEY.
LEVINE.
LOW.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK.
BY THE LAST.
YEAH.
I.
OKAY.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM SIX MISTER
SANTIAGO.
WOULD THAT BE A. B..
WAIT I KNOW IF I FIVE OH FIVE
PUT BIBLE FIVE OKAY.
WOULD WOULD YOU WILL BE OKAY IF
WE START OFF WITH TWENTY FIVE.
SEVEN FIVE MISTER CHAIR SINCE
THE WITNESSES ARE YOU SITTING
HERE WILL GO WITH THAT THEN
THINK ITEM SEVEN.
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU AND I'LL BE A BRIEF AT
THAT TO GET THE CHAIR.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVEN FIVE WOULD
ALLOW PRIVATE SCHOOLS INCLUDING
PAROCHIAL SCHOOLS TO ENTER CC. A
AP PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THEY DESERVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AFFORDED ANY OTHER
STUDENTS IN TRADITIONAL ON
PUBLIC SCHOOLS MISTER MISTER
CHAIR AND THAT WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES.
ONE WITNESS.
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU ARE
WONDERFUL TO BE UP HERE AGAIN.
THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IS A A SPONSOR
OF THE BILL WRITTEN BY SIMPLY
MEMBER.
SANTIAGO AND WE'RE VERY
COMMITTED TO BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE DUAL ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS.
JUST SOME STATISTICS NEARLY
HALF A MILLION CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN PRIVATE
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WITH OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND OF THE STUDENTS.
ENROLLED AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR.
THE DUAL ENROLLMENT IN LOS
ANGELES NEARLY TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS. A YEAR GRADUATE FROM
PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
MANY OF THE STUDENTS COME TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AND ALL
WHILE THEY'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CONCURRENT
ENROLLMENT. BUT THE DUAL
ENROLLMENT SYSTEM WOULD ALLOW US
TO SERVE THE STUDENTS MORE
EFFECTIVELY IN A PATHWAY THAT
CAN LEAD TOWARDS COLLEGE
COMPLETION.
WHAT PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE TUITION
BASED THERE A GREAT MANY LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THAT ARE SERVED
AS AN EXAMPLE THE CATHOLIC
EDUCATIONAL FOR?
FOUNDATION IN LOS ANGELES
FUNDED OVER NINE THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO STUDENTS LAST YEAR FOR A
TOTAL OF ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IS A
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SET AT
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY FIVE I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BRAVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE A LONGTIME
SUPPORTER OF THIS HE CAP PROGRAM
AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WAS THAT EVER
HAPPENED ON BEHALF BETWEEN
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT AND I APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTION AND THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO FOCUS ON
A LOW INCOME STUDENTS ATTENDING
PRIVATE SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
GIVE.
ANY TWEENER SO ON THIS BILL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SECOND.
MOONDANCE MOVED BY MISTER BLOOM
SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE MISTER SANTIAGO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE EXPECT
EFFORT AYE BUT.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
SECRETARY OF THE CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA.
BEFORE I VOTE I I'M SORRY I
FORGOT TO.
I'M NOT. GONNA.
THANK THE MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD AND I AGREE
WITH THIS ATTACK.
BUT I WANT TO STATE THAT WE
DON'T WANNA.
VERY MUCH.
.
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
INADVERTENTLY LEAVING OUT AND
REPRESENTED STUDENTS
ATTENDING PRIVATE AND PAROCHIAL
SCHOOLS. FROM BENEFITING FROM
DUAL AROMA ON ENROLLMENT.
HOWEVER I STRONGLY ADVISE THE
AUTHOR TO. CONTINUE TO WORK
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS AS
OUTLINED ON PAGES THREE AND FOUR
OF THE ANALYSIS. I'M COMMITTING
A COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY BUT OF THE ISSUES
RAISED IN THE HOUSES OF NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED. BY THE TIME THE BILL
REACHES THE FLOOR A RIP PRESERVE
MY RIGHT TO VOTE IN A DIFFERENT
WAY.
AND PLEASE
I KEEP THE COMMITTEE STAFF
ABREAST ON THE WORK.
AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU TO THE OTHER.
MEDINA AYE.
MEDINA AYE BAKER. ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
IRWIN.
KILEY.
LEVINE.
LOW.
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO AYE AYE SANTIAGO AYE
WEBER.
WEBER I.
FOUR ZERO THAT BILL IS ON CALL
AND WE WILL GO TO YOUR NEXT BILL
MISTER SANTIAGO.
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FIVE OH FIVE.
I THINK IMAGE TRAMP MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ON THE AB TWENTY FIVE A
FIVE. PART WAS SIMPLY ASK THE
CSU REPORT THE LEGISLATURE ON IT
LEGISLATURE ON IT'S A BUDGET AND
PRACTICES SPECIFIC TO IT'S A
STATE SPENDING.
I A RECENTLY AUDITOR'S REPORT
FOUND THE CAMPUS IS DO NOT
ADEQUATELY OVERSEE THEIR BUDGETS
SPECIFICALLY CAMPUS IS NOT HAVE
WRITTEN POLICIES REQUIRING
PERIODIC. COMPARISONS OF
SPENDING LEVELS TO ITS BUDGET
LIMITS.
I AM IN FACT A LAST YEAR THE
CSU.
A BOARD OF TRUSTEES VOTED TO
INCREASE THEIR THEIR TUITION IS
ON TRACK TO DO THE SAME THING
CITING MORE THAN EVER TODAY.
IT WOULD BE PRUDENT TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE WITH AN AUDIT
OTHER WOULD HELP US TO IDENTIFY
A COST SAVINGS POTENTIALLY. AND
THE. PREVENTING STUDENTS FROM
AGAIN TUITION HIKES IF WE COULD
POTENTIALLY DO THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES AND THAT HAVE ONE WITNESS.
TWO WITNESSES.
THAT BACKWARDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DENY
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
WITH ONE I THINK.
AS THE MEMBER.
SANTIAGO FOR.
PUTTING THIS FORWARD I SEE IF A
REPRESENTS TWENTY THOUSAND
FACULTY LIBRARIANS COACHES AND
CANCERS IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. A SYSTEM
WHICH SERVES MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE A COUPLE REASONS
WHY WE NEED THIS BILL. ARE AS
JUST MENTIONED THERE IS AN AUDIT
HEARING OF THIS YES YOU WERE
MANY THERE WERE MANY MAJOR
FINDINGS WERE DISCUSSED IT WAS
FOUND ONE OF THOSE FINDINGS WAS
THAT THE CSU WAS NOT DOING.
PERIODIC REVIEWS OF THE CAMPUS
BUDGETS
I BELIEVE THAT WE BELIEVE THAT A
REGULAR AUDIT WILL ENSURE THAT
THE CSU FULLY IMPLEMENTS UP
PROPER OR FISCAL OVERSIGHT. AND
THAT THEY AND THAT THIS WILL
REQUIRE THE CSU TO PUT IN PLACE
GOOD BUDGET PROCESS SEES AS WELL
AS ALLOW THE PUBLIC IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE. FULLY AWARE
OF THESE CHANGES AT THE SAME
HEARING THE CSU WAS ALSO ASKED
HOW THEY MAKE HIRING DECISIONS
THE CSU'S RESPONSE WITH THE
COMPASS THAT CAMPUSES MAKE
HIRING DECISIONS. ARE ONE
POSITION AT A TIME.
AT THIS I THINK HEARING IT WAS
DISCUSSED THAT THERE WERE MAJOR
INCREASES IN EXECUTIVE AND
MANAGEMENT POSITIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE CSU
TO RIVER REVIEW THEIR CURRENT
HIRING PRACTICES AND COMPARE
THEM TO THE UC AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND FINALLY COME BACK.
OUT TO THE LEGISLATURE WITH
PROPOSED CHANGES TO IMPROVING
THOSE PRACTICES.
ADDITIONALLY LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATORS HAVE ASKED US FOR
THE NUMBER OF QUALIFIED STUDENTS
THAT WERE NOT ADMITTED INTO THE
CSU THEY HAVE ASKED US FOR
INFORMATION INFORMATION SUCH AS
WHERE THE STUDENTS APPLIED FROM.
WHERE THEY APPLY TO YOU AND
OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
ABOUT THEM WHILE THE CSU MAY
HAVE THE NUMBER THEY DO NOT
PROVIDE?
THIS IN FOR THIS AND OTHER
INFORMATION WE BELIEVE THAT
LEGISLATORS AND THE PUBLIC
SHOULD HAVE THIS.
I CLOSING GOVERNOR BROWN ARE
RECENTLY SAID THAT THE CSU HAS
TO LEARN TO LIVE WITHIN THEIR
MEANS WHILE WE MAY NOT AGREE
WITH THE UNDERLYING ISSUE OF.
FUNDING THAT PROMPTED THAT
STATEMENT BECAUSE.
THE SYSTEM IS IN FACT UNDER
FUNDED WE DO BELIEVE THAT.
YES YES YOU MUST BE MORE TRENT
IF MORE TRANSPARENT SYSTEM
ALLOWING LEGISLATORS AND THE
PUBLIC TO KNOW MORE ABOUT HOW
THE CSU SPENDS ITS FUNDS. WILL
ALLOW LEGISLATORS AND THE PUBLIC
TO HOLD THE SYSTEM MORE
ACCOUNTABLE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND WE ASK FOR YOUR IBOOK.
CHIP MEDINA MEMBERS SAID DAVID
BELL HAWKINS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES
UNION.
TH THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO
HURT AUTHORING THIS BILL WE HAVE
WORKED WITH DOCTOR WEBER LAST
YEAR.
I'M ON THE A PAYROLL.
RELEASE OF THE APRIL TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NOT AT THAT
LOOKED AT HER MANAGEMENT GROWTH
AS WELL AS BUDGET ACCOUNTABILITY
AT SEARS YOU CAMPUSES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATION
AND I NOT ONLY ADDRESSES THE
SCOPE OF BUT MORE IMPORTANT IN
SOME WAYS IS THE INTENT OF THAT
ON IT. A WONDER THE MORE
DISTURBING CONCLUSIONS OF THE
AUDITOR.
WAS THAT STE.
SEE IF YOU CAN'T PURPOSES WERE
UNABLE TO DOCUMENT TO THE
AUDITOR HOW THEY SPEND STATE
MONEY.
UNABLE TO DOCUMENT TO THE
AUDITOR HOW THEY SPEND STATE
MONEY THERE BY QUESTIONING
WHETHER THEY'RE DOING IT
EFFICIENTLY AND APPROPRIATELY AS
POINTED OUT IN EUROPE ANALYSIS.
I WOULD THINK THAT SEE IF YOU
WOULD WELCOME THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IT'S CLEAR FROM WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
ARE FROM FROM THE ARCTIC
CONCLUSIONS.
FROM THE.
THE ENQUIRIES HAVE BEEN MADE BY
MR SANTIAGO AND OTHERS.
I THAT THERE IS A.
.
INABILITY.
OF THE CSU IS CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED TO HAVE THEIR BUDGET.
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
AND IT LACKS ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT
WE THINK THIS BILL IS IT IS A
VERY IMPORTANT FIRST STEP.
HERE I FELT.
THANK YOU.
ANY TWEENER WHO'S.
ANY OPPOSITION PLEASE GO FOR.
BUT WE HAD TWEET ó I'M SORRY.
FOR.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
EDUARDO SL YOU CALIFORNIANS
WORK.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO YOUR SUPPORT.
NOW ANY.
WINNERS.
OPPOSITION COMING FORWARD.
BUT A GOOD AFTERNOON ENJOY
WATCHING US CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
WE REGRETTABLY MUST BE OPPOSED
TO THE MEASURE OF YOUR POPE WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE FOR
THREE REASONS ONE.
WE DID JUST GO TO THIS
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT REPORT
REQUIREMENT.
PROCESS HAMPER THAT PROCESS WE
HAVE MET.
ALMOST ALL OF THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE AUDIT. OF ALL THE
FIGHTING THE AUDIT THEIR COUPLE
STRINGERS OUT THERE THAT OUT
LYING BECAUSE OF.
TECHNOLOGY IMPROVEMENTS OPTICAL
TIME TO TO IMPLEMENT. AND
BECAUSE OF A LABOR NEGOTIATION
PROCESS THAT HAS GONE THROUGH
THE PROCESS.
A ADDITIONALLY WE PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
NUMEROUS REPORTS SOME OF THESE
REPORTS ARE ARE DUPLICATIVE OF
WHAT'S REQUIRED IN THIS BILL AS
WELL. AND THE REASON WHY REST
REPOSE IS BECAUSE OF THE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
AUDITING.
CLEARLY WE HAVE REPORTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE BUDGET
PROCESS.
.
POOR LEGISLATIVE MANDATE.
AND WE HAVE MET THE TARGETS OF
THE AUDIT REQUEST.
SO FAR AND BECAUSE THAT WE JUST
WE JUST DON'T SEE WHY THIS BUILD
MERITED. AYE WITH ME TODAY'S
BRAD WELL SOCIALIZED CHANCELLOR
THE CSU AS WELL.
MAINTENANCE OF TIME I WON'T.
READ THE STATEMENT BUT JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE AUDIT MADE
THIRTEEN RECOMMENDATIONS WE'VE
COMPLIED WITH TEN OF THE
THIRTEEN IS ANDY MENTIONED THREE
OF THEM. HAVE LONGER
IMPLEMENTATION TYLER TIMELINES
SPECIFICALLY THE STATE AUDITOR'S
ALREADY ACCEPTED OUR RESPONSES
WITH REGARD TO THE BUDGET
OVERSIGHT.
WHICH WAS RAISED BY EARLIER IN
THE DISCUSSION. AND WE'VE SINCE
IMPLEMENTED THAT PROVIDES POLICY
ALSO AND POINT OUT THAT THE
AUDITORS DID I DID NOT FIND ANY
CAMPUS THAT OVERSPENT ITS BUDGET
BUT RATHER DIDN'T HAVE ADEQUATE
POLICIES IN THE AUDITOR'S
OPINION WE'VE RECTIFIED THAT WE
BELIEVE.
SO THAT THAT SO. SHOULD SUFFICE
TERMS OF THE UP BUDGET OVERSIGHT
ISSUE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SANTIAGO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND THAT JUST FOR THE RECORD I'D
LIKE A BICU MAY NOT BE AWARE.
DETERMINED FROM THE CSU BUT I
WAS SENT A LETTER IN A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO REQUESTING ON SOME
INFORMATION BUT YOU GET AN
ANSWER THAT I I WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
I.
OUTSIDE OF THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I DON'T.
BUT I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD
AND THANK YOU FOR AGREEING. TO
THE AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO COMMEND CS
YOU. FOR THE WORK THEY'VE DONE
FOLLOWING THE RELEASE OF THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT LAST
YEAR.
I VERY MUCH BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE PLAYS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE AND OVERSIGHT IN THE
OPERATIONS OF BUDGETING. OF ALL
THE SEGMENTS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
AND I SUPPORT. UP ANY EFFORTS
FOR TRANSPARENCY.
I WITH THAT I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
NO I'M OF.
SO MOVED BY DOCTOR WEBER.
DO WE HAVE A SECOND.
ON THIS BILL.
THE SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MADAM SECRETARY OF YOU'D CALL
THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHáVEZ IRWIN KILEY.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO AYE AYE SANTIAGO AYE
WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO THAT WILL BE ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
TO TO TO DO.
TO.
ANY TIME.
CHECK WE NEED THE TIMER SAID.
.
RECOMMENDED TAKE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWO NINE THREE THREE
CHAIR MEDINA THAT ONE SOUNDS
GOOD TO START WITH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT A. B. TWENTY
NINE THIRTY THREE. A BILL THAT
EXPANDS ON THE SUCCESSFUL TENURE
MODEL THAT CONNECTS COUNTY AND
SOCIAL WORKERS. WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COUNSELORS.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY THREE
WOULD REQUIRE COUNTIES TO
DESIGNATE. A HIGHER EDUCATION
LIAISON WITHIN THE WELFARE
DEPARTMENTS AT A PUT.
AS A POINT OF CONTACT.
THE GOAL ISN'T IS TO IMPROVE.
COORDINATION WITH COUNTIES ON
LINKING ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
TO PUBLICLY FUNDED SERVICES.
STATISTICS HAVE HIGHLIGHTED
STRUGGLES.
FACED BY MANY STUDENTS
TODAY A INCLUDING DIVERSE AND
OFTEN. LOW INCOME STUDENTS
STUDENTS.
THIRTY SIX PERCENT OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS SAY THAT THEY ARE FOOD
INSECURE. AND HOUSING INSECURE
ONE NINE PERCENT REPORT BEING
HOMELESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. IS SENT VIA
MOSQUEDA.
EL CAMINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COUNSELOR WITH WHOM THE BILL
IDEA.
CAME FROM AND ALSO REBEKAH
GONZALEZ FROM THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AGAIN
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA MUSCAT I AM
I'M A COUNSELOR AT ALL
COMMUNICABLE ITCH AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL'S SPONSOR
AS WELL AS THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
IN MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE BESIDES
BE ACCOUNTS ARE MOST OF THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FIRST YEAR
EXPERIENCE PROGRAM. AS A AS AN
ACADEMIC COUNSELLOR ON STUDENTS
ARE INCREASINGLY SHARING THEIR
LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT INTEL
SUCH ISSUES OF POVERTY.
HOMELESSNESS FOOD INSECURITY
MENTAL ILLNESS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE
IF I CAN IDENTIFY A STUDENT FOR
ELIGIBLE CAMPUS SERVICES SUCH AS
CAO WORKS YOU APPEAR YOU CAN
ASK.
OUR DEITY SBS I CAN QUICKLY
REFER THEM THERE HOWEVER NOT ALL
STUDENTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEY AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS FUNDED ON THROUGH
THE COUNTY. AYE MANY YEARS AGO I
HAD A STUDENT WHO HAD BECOME
EMANCIPATED FOSTER CARE YOUTH I
REACHED OUT TO THE SERVICES MY
COMMUNITY AND WITH THAT ABLE TO
FIND HIM PERMANENT PLACEMENT.
I I QUICKLY THOUGHT OF MY SISTER
WHO IS AN MSW SOCIAL WORKER
EMPLOYED BY THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND WITH IN MINUTES SHE
HAD A REFERRAL FORM FOR ME WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHAT MY STUDENT NEED
IT. I'VE SPOKEN TO COUNTER THE
UP AND DOWN THE STATE IN THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT MANY OF US SPACE.
I'M NOT EVERYONE IS LUCKY ENOUGH
TO HAVE A SISTER WHO WORKS FOR
THE COUNTY. THAT'S HOW WE CAME
UP WITH THE IDEA FOR AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY THREE TO ALLOW FOR A
COUNTY LIAISON FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION TO WORK TOGETHER WITH
COUNCILS LIKE ME FOR THIS VERY
PURPOSE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE SOME SUCCESSFUL MODELS OF
COUNTIES AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALREADY WORKING TOGETHER
COLLABORATIVELY. PARTICULARLY IN
ORANGE COUNTY WHERE THEY CAN
OTHER COUNTY VOLUNTARY SET UP
ITS VERY MODEL FOR THE CAL WORKS
POPULATION. AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY THREE WILL SCALE THIS UP
AND WILL ULTIMATELY HELP CONNECT
MORE STUDENTS WITH PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES WHICH THEY MIGHT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NSW WAS
PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY THREE AS A REFLECTS
THE NEED FOR INCREASED
COMMUNICATION AND DIALOGUE
BETWEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
COUNTIES ON SERVING THE STUDENT
POPULATION. ONE APPROPRIATELY
REFERRED TO THE RIGHT PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES SOCIAL WORKERS WILL
BE THE ONES WORKING WITH THE
STUDENTS TO ADDRESS THEIR BASIC
HUMAN NEEDS LIKE HOUSING. FOOD
AND MENTAL HEALTH WHICH THEN
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD OF THEM
SUCCEEDING IN SCHOOL. THIS SPELL
IT'S A WIN WIN FOR COUNTIES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND STUDENTS
AND DESERVES YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANYWAY THIS IS AN OPPOSITION.
ANY OTHER COMMENTARY IN BETWEEN
OR OTHERWISE.
TO CHERISH LIKE CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE RIVAL.
THIS IS A DO PASSED TO.
TO HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
ADAM PLEASE QUOTE BUT WE NEED A
MOTION.
IN A MOTION A SECOND PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER AYE
AYE BAKER AYE ARAMBULA. BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ IRWIN KILEY
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
OKAY THAT'S FIVE ZERO AN ON CALL
LET'S TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
.
GOOD AFTERNOON. TODAY I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
SIX.
THIS BILL WILL REMOVE THE SUNSET
DATE AND PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE.
ALLOWING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA
AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
TO USE BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT
METHODOLOGY.
INDEFINITELY.
THIS ALLOWS THE UNIVERSITIES TO
HAVE FLEXIBLE OPTIONS.
ALLOWING THEM TO MAKE WISE
PROCUREMENT COST SAVING
DECISIONS.
RATHER THAN HAVING TO SELECT THE
LOWEST COST BETTER. THE BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT METHODOLOGY
ALLOWS CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND UC TO CONSIDERED
NON COST FACTORS SUCH AS QUALITY
EXPERIENCE AND THE LIFE CYCLE
COSTS WHEN SELECTING VENDORS.
CURRENT LAW PURSUANT TO SENATE
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY. AUTHORIZED
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE UC TO USE BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT METHODOLOGY.
ON A PILOT BASIS FOR FIVE YEARS.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WAS REQUIRED TO REVIEW THE PILOT
PROGRAM.
BUT COULD NOT COMPLETE THE STUDY
DURING THE ORIGINAL TIMEFRAME. A
ONE YEAR EXTENSION WAS GRANTED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THE
REPORT WAS ISSUED IN DECEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND. SEVENTEEN.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE UC MADE A
REASONABLE USE. OF THE BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT AND
RECOMMENDED THAT THEY BE ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE.
IT'S USE
WITH ME TODAY IS JASON MURPHY
FROM THE UC OFFICE OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON MURPHY BEHALF THE
UNIVERSE TO CALIFORNIA.
PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WERE
OFFERING OUR SPONSOR THIS BILL
IF YOU SAY DO I THINK THE AUTHOR
MR MEDINA FOR KAREN THIS BILL
FORWARD. I THINK THE AUTHOR DID
A GREAT JOB DESCRIBING THE THE
BACKGROUND HERE IS YOU ALL MAY
RECALL WE'VE BEEN THROUGH WITH
UNIVERSAL CALIFORNIA THIS
COMMITTEE SEVERAL TIMES. IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS ASKING FOR HELP
AND ASSISTANCE AND AND AYE VOTES
ON OUR BEST VALUE BILLS WORK
MOST RECENTLY WITH MISTER LEVINE
ON BESTBUY CONSTRUCTION. JUST
LAST YEAR AND THAT.
AUTHORITIES NOW GRANTED THAT
UNIVERSAL ONGOING BASIS THIS IS
ALL ABOUT THE UNIVERSITY TRYING
TO DO MORE WITH LESS AND STRETCH
YOUR DOLLAR WE BELIEVE BEST
VALUE AUTHORITY. ALLOWS
OURSELVES DO THAT'S WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL INNOCENTS
APART THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD
MCCALLUM GRIP ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS RIOS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT I WOULD
ECHO.
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE UC AND AND SAY THIS IS
A NOTHER TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
FOR.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HIGHER
EDUCATION ENTITIES.
TO TO.
ECONOMIZE AT.
AND SAVE MONEY IN THE LONG RUN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT JUST A.
ME TOO.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON WAS THAT EVER AT ON
BEHALF BE COLLEGE LEAGUE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND ANYONE IN BETWEEN THERE YOU
GO YOU'RE DOING THAT FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE I THOUGHT I'D
WAIT. I AM.
MICROBES HERE ON BEHALF OF
QUEST DIAGNOSTICS ON SO SO WE
ARE WE'RE NOT IN SUPPORT WE'RE
REALLY NINE IN OPPOSE THE THERE
AND WHICH HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL AND AND AND AND A
PRIME ONE JUST MAKE IT CLEAR
WHAT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS TO HELP. ME OUT
WITH THIS I. AM ONE QUEST
DIAGNOSTICS TESTIFIED IN BUDGET
SUB TO LAST YEAR ON ON AN ISSUE
INVOLVING.
ON IN THE GEN DIS EASE ITEM
INVOLVING A. THAT THE PUT
POTENTIAL LOSS OF THE CONTRACT
AT THE UCLA MEDICAL CENTER ON
FROM MOVING WORK FROM THE SENATE
THERE SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO LAB TO
THE UNIT AT TO ADD. AN ENTITY
CALLED A ARE YOU P. WHICH IS AN
ARM OF THE UNIVERSITY OF UTAH.
AND I TESTIFYING IN THAT HEARING
AND AND THREE.
IN THE END USE THAT IS THAT THEY
MOVE THE WORK THEY MOVE THE
CONTRACTED LABORATORY SERVICES
FROM UCLA MEDICAL CENTER TO OUR
DIFFERENT FROM SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO TO THE UNIVERSITY YOU
TIE A ARE YOU P. LAB. AND A AND
AND SINCE AND WE WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO AND GET SOME
ANSWERS AND AS AN ASSEMBLYMAN
MCCARTY AS CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ASKED. ASKED DO YOU
SEE THIRD PROVIDE HIM
INFORMATION ON THE COST SAVINGS
THAT THAT RESULTED FROM FROM
MOVING THAT. THAT GOT SERVICES
CONTRACT AND THAT YASSER THAT IN
NOVEMBER NOVEMBER NINTH IN AND.
THANKS TO TERRACE ONLY MEDINA
IF SOMEONE MCCARTY ACTUALLY GOT
AN ANSWER THAT I'M NOVEMBER
NIGHT REQUEST ON FRIDAY. AND SO
I'M AND THAT THAT RISK THAT THAT
RESPONSE WAS LACKING DETAIL JUST
HAD SOME NUMBERS WITH NO
DOCUMENTATION TO BACK IT UP
WHICH IS ACTUALLY WHAT. SIMON
MCCARTY ASK FOR SO LONG WAVE
BREED OF SAYING THAT. IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT WE REALLY SUPPORT
THE HECK OUT OF BEST VALUE
CONTRACTING INDUSTRY IT YEAH IF
IF WHAT WE WE BELIEVE THE BEST I
COULD CONTRACTING MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE. WE DON'T WE DON'T THINK
AND IN THE CONTRACT THAT QUEST
DIAGNOSTICS LOST TO THIS UTAH
LAB WAS NOT A BEST VALUE
CONTRACT APPARENTLY SIR IT WAS A
SERVICES CONTRACT. IN THEORY
BASED ON PRICE ALTHOUGH WE
THERE'S NO THEY THEY HAVEN'T
JUSTIFIED ANYTHING TO SHOW THAT
THEY AND SAVE MONEY.
I'M WHAT WHAT WE WOULDN'T WHAT
WE WOULD REQUEST THIS IS BILL
GOES FORWARD. IS IS TO THINK
ABOUT AND SOME OF THE
DEFINITIONS IN THE BILL IT SAYS
BEST VALUE PRICING AS DETERMINED
BY THE YOU SEE AN AND I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW THIS COMMITTEES
HEARD SOME SOME ISSUES ON
CONTRACTING PRACTICES THAT YOU
SEE IN THE EVENING AND YOU MIGHT
WANT TO. PUT SOME TEETH ON THAT
ARE PUT SOME PARAMETERS AROUND
WHAT WHAT THE UC DETERMINES THE
BEST PRICE TO BE AND IF THEY IF
IT'S JUST UP TO YOU SEE A MEAN
SORT OF ARBITRARY.
AND AND WE THINK THAT I'M. YOU
KNOW.
EVEN THE EVEN THE CONTRACTED IT
THAT WHAT THE LABS FOR SERVICES
CONTRACT WITH A ARE YOU P.
SHOULD SHOULD YOU KNOW FIT SOME
OF THESE THINGS IF THE UC IS THE
ECONOMIC ENGINE THAT DRIVES
CALIFORNIA. AND WORKED THAT IT
SKIPS CONTRACTING OUT FOR
LABORATORY SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE.
SHOULD BE DONE CALIFORNIA WE
THINK THAT YOU KNOW E. YOU'RE
GONNA IF YOU DID MEDICAL
RESEARCH AND ALL THE THINGS THAT
FLOW WITH THIS WORK TO YOU TARA.
IS ALL GOING TO FLOW TO YOU TIME
IN PEOPLE WHO ARE ARE ARE YOU
KNOW GRADUATE STUDENTS IN THE
UNIVERSE UTAH. WILL HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF DRIVING THE UTAH
ECONOMY RATHER THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY SO I'M AS DUMB AS FORD I
WANNA KEEP WORKING WITH MR
MEDINA BECAUSE HE'S BEEN GREAT.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE
AND A HAVE A NICE DAY AS LONG
TWO MINUTES THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
FOR THE PUBLIC.
.
DOWNTURN BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SHOULD YOU HAVE A APPOINTS AYE
AYE I'VE SUPPORTED LEGISLATION
ON BEST VALUE ANKLE INCLUDING
FOR YOU SEE TO GIVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY I'M I'M I'M NOT
SUPPORTIVE OF REMOVING THE
SUNSET FOR TWO REASONS.
ONE.
AND THIS IS OF MORE A FUNCTION
OF HOW MUCH WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
LOOKING FOR A NEW DAY AND YOU
PROGRESS AND CONTINUE PROGRESS
AND IN GOOD ADMINISTRATIVE
DECISION MAKING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE SHOULD
BE A PARTNER IN THAT BEST VALUE
IS PART OF IT BUT I THINK.
IT IS APPROPRIATE TO HAVE A
SUNSET JUST BY VIRTUE OF THE
FACT THEY'RE SO MUCH CHANGE THAT
NEEDS TO CONTINUE HAPPENED YOU
SEE WITH THEIR. THEIR THEIR BEST
ADMINISTRATIVE PRACTICES
INCLUDING IN CONTRACTING.
AND I SO I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE A SUNSET AND
SECONDLY BEST VALUE ISN'T ISN'T
NOT.
THE LOWEST BID SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE TAXPAYERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
ON A REGULAR BASIS WE ARE
CHECKING THE BEST VALUE WAS
ALWAYS WORKING THE WAY IT
SHOULD.
AND.
THAT MAY MEAN A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET THAT'S A PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF TIME
PARTICULARLY FOR CONTRACTING IN
BUDGET PLANNING AND OTHERWISE
BUT I THINK FOR PURPOSES OF.
BOTH THE PUBLIC TRUST AND
ALWAYS REEVALUATING BEST BUY IS
THE WAY TO GO.
AS OPPOSED TO LOWEST BIDDING.
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE THAT CHECK
IN REGULARLY SO.
RESPECTFULLY WILL NOT BE SPRING
YOUR BILL MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT
APPRECIATE THAT WE HAVE BOTH
AGREED ON BEST VALUE IN THE
PAST.
AND WITHOUT THIS IS.
BEEN MOVED BY MISTER ARAMBULA
SECONDED BY MISTER SANTIAGO THIS
IS A DO PASSED TWO PROBES PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
I'M SORRY MISS YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
EXCUSE ME MISTER CHAIRMAN
KNOWLEDGE GO TO THE.
MEDINA I AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER
NOW BAKER NO ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I SHOT THIS.
IRWIN
KILEY
LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW.
PATTERSON
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
FIVE ONE IT'S ON CALL AND.
YOU'RE BACK SO I WILL GIVE YOU
THAT BACKS WE CAN START OUT ON.
LOTS TO DO.
OKAY.
IT'S GOING. YEAH
.
NO.
WE'RE MISSING LET KNOW WE'RE
DONE I DON'T THINK. YOU ADD ON
CONTENT BY WATER.
THERE
.
WELL.
ERICA HILL.
BECAUSE.
YOU ARE GOING. YEAH.
OKAY. ITEM ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN
NINETY SIX.
BAKER AYE BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
SHOP.
BLOOM AYE.
CHAVEZ.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE PATTERSON.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B..
EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX IS OUT
ELEVEN ZERO WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
I AM TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY AND BAKER AYE
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
CHAVEZ.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
SANTIAGO.
IT'S JUST FOUNDER
CHAVEZ.
BEGIN THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CHAVEZ I.
TWELVE ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDARS UP WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY.
BAKER.
BAKER NO.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ NO IRWIN.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO.
PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM THREE
AB TWENTY ONE SIX
NINE THREE THE BILL IS OUT WE
KEEP IT OPEN FOR.
ITEM FOR AB TWENTY TO TWENTY.
BAKER.
BAKER NO.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
IRWIN.
IRWIN NOT BOATING.
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
FOR A. B..
TO GO ANY.
EIGHT THREE THE BILL IS OUT WE
WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
ONE BAKER.
BAKER NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE SCHABAS.
CHAVEZ NO. IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO LEVINE. LEVINE AYE LOW.
PATTERSON.
FIVE AB TWENTY.
ONE EIGHT THREE THE BILL IS OUT
WE.
IT OPENED FOR.
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FIVE OH FIVE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE SCHABAS.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LOW.
PATTERSON
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FIVE OH FIVE.
ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WE
WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE. BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I
CHAVEZ.
SHOPPERS AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
ITEM SEVEN A. B.
FIVE SEVEN.
THE BILL IS OUT.
BUT OPEN.
I DON'T EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN. BLOOM.
BLOOM I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I KILEY.
KILEY AYE LOW.
PATTERSON.
NINE TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
LEAVE IT OPEN.
MEMBERS.
I AM TEN AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
ONE.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM TEN A. B.
EIGHT NINETY ONE
CLOSER.
ITEM ELEVEN A. B.. TWO NINE
THREE THREE. ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
AYE SCHABAS
SCHABAS I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LOW.
PATTERSON
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE WEBER.
ELEVEN A. B..
ITEM TWELVE AB THREE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE SHOWBIZ
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
WELL TWELVE ZERO A. B..
BOTH A
BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE IT OPEN.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTY EIGHTY
NINE. BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE SHOWBIZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE OH ONE.
BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE SCHABAS.
CHáVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
JEAN A V.
THE ONE ó ONE TWELVE ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
AND MEMBERS.
I AM FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX.
SCHABAS.
CHAVEZ NO IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SIX.
KILEY NO.
LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
I DO.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
THREE THE BILL IS OUT WE
LEAVE IT OPEN.
ITEM SIXTEEN A. B..
THREE TWO ONE THREE. BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
AB.
THIRTEEN
ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
IT OPENS.
VOTING.
WHY WOULD I DON'T WANT OUT?
YOU THAT YOU VOTED.
YEAH.
OKAY.
FEDERAL THE OF GOD.
WE'LL START THE BEGINNING AGAIN.
YEAH.
OKAY SO. NUMBER ONE A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETIES THAT.
CHAVEZ.
SHOP AS I.
PATTERSON.
WELL ZERO ITEM ONE A. B. EIGHT
NINE SIX.
BILL IS OUT WE WILL KEEP IT
OPEN.
IT I I DON'T TO AB TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE CONSENT CALENDAR
LOW. LOW AYE.
ZERO CONSENT CALENDARS OUT WILL
KEEP IT OPEN
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY.
PATTERSON.
NINE THREE.
ITEM THREE NINE NINE THREE
TWENTY ONE.
SIXTY
YOU WOULD OPEN PER ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM FOR AB TWENTY TO
TWENTY.
PATTERSON.
FOR.
THREE.
TWENTY TO TWENTY WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT.
ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
ONE LOW. LOW AYE PATTERSON.
THREE.
FIVE.
THREE SIXTY ONE WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR.
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FIVE OH FIVE.
LOW LOW AYE PATTERSON.
WELL ZERO.
SIX
AB FIVE OH FIVE WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT.
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE.
LOW.
LOW AYE.
KILEY VOTE CHANGE NO TO YES.
SEVEN.
TWELVE ZERO.
BUT OPEN FOR.
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN.
PATTERSON.
ZERO ITEM A WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NINE AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR. LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
WELL ZERO ITEM NINE TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR.
BUT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
ONE PATTERSON.
AND TWELVE ZERO KEEP IT OPEN.
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM IN LEBANON
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY THREE LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
ITEM ELEVEN.
TWELVE ZERO WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR HER ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM TWELVE AB THREE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT PATTERSON.
TWELVE TWELVE ZERO WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTY EIGHTY
NINE LOW.
LOW AYE.
ZERO.
AND MEMBERS.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB THIRTY ONE NO
ONE PATTERSON.
I ITEM FOURTEEN.
THE WONDERFUL ONE.
I DON'T FOURTEEN.
PATTERSON I.
YES.
SO I DON'T FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
I AM FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO.
I'D OF.
FOR A BI
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SIX IS OUT.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTEEN.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING.
SIXTEEN A. B. THIRTY TWO
THIRTEEN ELEVEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
OKAY SO LONG FILE ORDER.
ITEM ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY
SIX
PATTERSON. PATTERSON AYE.
ITEM ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY
SIX THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT.
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO.
I DON'T THREE AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY NINE FOR THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM FOUR AB TWENTY TO TWENTY.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO.
ITEM FOR AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT FOR THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
ONE.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO.
A. B.
ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY THREE.
THE ONE NINE FOUR THAT BILL IS
OUT.
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FIVE OH FIVE
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING.
SIX AB TWENTY FIVE OF FIVE
TWELVE ZERO BILL IS OUT.
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I.
SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE.
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHT A B. TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO.
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN.
THREE THAT BILL IS OUT.
I AM NINE AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING.
NINE A. B.
A SEVEN EIGHT
FOUR TWELVE ZERO THAT BILL IS
THAT.
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
ONE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I.
TEN A TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE.
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY THREE.
PATTERSON PATTERSON AYE.
ELEVEN AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY
THREE.
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TWELVE AB THREE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I.
OF A BEAT THIRTY SO EIGHT
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
THAT ONE'S.
THE.
AND. WHAT I BURDEN?
THAT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON POLICY.
BUSY BUSY.